[SPEAKER_03]: yes i'm full of wings oh nice those wings looks great look great honestly yeah let's see i mean it wasn't a fancy restaurant but it's a good restaurant i don't even like fancy restaurants like i don't like pretentious food i like good food yeah fancy restaurants like you pay like so much for absolutely nothing yeah true
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, this is working, this is working.
[SPEAKER_05]: Did we all get a haircut?
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we all did, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: I haven't got a haircut, I've just gotten one here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, nice.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I don't know if Calder... Calder needs to change his cap.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I got a different cap, you know?
[SPEAKER_06]: I've been wasting every day with a different cap on.
[SPEAKER_06]: This is just my hair, like, I had it in the hairdresser for a month or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what were we doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, yeah, we were dying.
[SPEAKER_00]: Other people died.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy killed people.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not you guys yet.
[SPEAKER_07]: All right, we're in a fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, we are in a fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you guys aren't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy's in a fight.
[SPEAKER_05]: You guys are chilling.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mine are fighting.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not in a fight.
[SPEAKER_07]: My dark mode disappeared.
[SPEAKER_07]: How the fuck can I get it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, that should be somewhere in settings and I think.
[SPEAKER_04]: Graphics.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, accessibility.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Uh, let me see.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Change your character.
[SPEAKER_01]: Change your characters.
[SPEAKER_04]: Check the spell.
[SPEAKER_04]: Dramatic music.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, we're in here.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're in good.
[SPEAKER_02]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll do the introductions, I guess, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and we'll record, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, we can start with you, Eske.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, this is Eske.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is the beautiful Dilliam.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is Calder.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Last session, well, before we get into last session, I guess, the five of you brought together by Theo's assassination found yourselves being, let's say, hunted through the city by various peoples, seemingly the Guild of Engineers, the Porter's Guild, potentially others like House of Elan and such things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seems like all of you guys have your own individual
[SPEAKER_02]: let's say histories alongside this combined history of Theo's assassination and your association with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: In particular, the Porter's Guild, two agents tracked you down to the Plum and Bob where they intended to be looking for people who worked with Theo and you uncovered through getting a ledger from one of Theo's other co-workers that Theo had been doing some
[SPEAKER_02]: Off the books work to get certain things delivered to certain scrap yards throughout the city, one of which being
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, is it Claring Bones or Claring?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not Bones, is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's Claring.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, Claring.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you changed it up a bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I keep saying.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then now it's Claring Bold.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think it's Claring Bold.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I just say Bones, and now it's, so therefore it's Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think it's Claring Bolds, actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, at Claring Bolds, where Billy actually works,
[SPEAKER_02]: It seemed that that was linked via this ledger to Theo alongside effects field scrapers where Felix now works, having investigated these supposed connections to Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: What you found was the Portis Guild
[SPEAKER_02]: Following them to the Head of Steam, which is a sort of clubhouse of sorts, a pub that is frequented by the Head of Steam, you made some inquiries.
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder used his dice playing skills and intimidation skills to get some information, whilst Asuka also did his bard stuff and got himself an audience with
[SPEAKER_02]: people there, where you found out that Evan Langford and Evan's crew were supposedly behind these investigations into Theo's work, and they were linked to these two agents that you found out to be called Gertrude and Alastair, alongside that there was a fourth man in the room, a mysterious masked figure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That made his way out of the room scaring Billy on his way out by walking through the wall and then Seemingly scaring himself by encountering Billy and disappearing from the from the scene as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Luckily it seems for you guys as Calder later Explained that this man was incredibly dangerous and not to be trifled with so you guys made it back to climbing bolts where you But shrapnel has been seemingly kidnapped from earlier and is now no longer running as a scrap yard
[SPEAKER_02]: And Calder went to check on his parents.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, also, we should mention that Felix was a scratcher during this period of time of escaping from the head of steam and transformed himself back into a person in front of everyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: at Claring Bolts as well, much to the shock and surprise of everyone and potentially himself as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did some work at Fexfield Scrappers as well, Felix, and you guys came back together in the midday, having checked on everyone's parents.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everyone seemed to be doing fine, luckily.
[SPEAKER_02]: And oh, one other thing, lots of things happened.
[SPEAKER_02]: last time as well, you also found on returning to Claring Boulds that
[SPEAKER_02]: you surmise the two employees, Alfie and Hollis, seemingly used the morning with no one there to basically get into the safe in the back room of Shrapnel's office, which had previously gone unfound by you guys when you were searching the place, and have emptied the safe with brute force, taking with them who knows what.
[SPEAKER_02]: So quite a lot of bits going on, but the important part was that around about midday, Billy got a knock on the gate and went over to answer it, as a good employee should, to find a delivery man and a driver in a large crate, which he answered.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, once
[SPEAKER_02]: I think for Billy, he was just unsure how to take the delivery exactly, but the man seemed to believe that he was impeding the delivery in some way, so attempted to strike Billy, who promptly thunder waved them across the street, killing the delivery man, injuring the driver, and actually mocking the driver unconscious, I should say, and shattering the crate on the back of the cart, more importantly,
[SPEAKER_02]: whereby you heard a roar as a creature emerged from the crate directly in front of you, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you put the creature on the screen again?
[SPEAKER_02]: I can, but the creature looks different now.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: The creature is a sort of eight foot amalgamation of human and metal a core glow inside his chest through a seems seemingly have been like surgically inserted these pieces of metal and metal are
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, a fully metal arm where you can see that they're like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like fully attached to his body like pieces of his flesh have been pulled over and riveted into the metal itself.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it is not a clean or tidy thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: by any means and he is yeah as I said eight feet tall so whilst he is humanoid he is large and his arms are like tree trunk size like he is big uh in this case and he you know he counts as a large creature let's put it that way so he is a big guy
[SPEAKER_02]: He kind of roared as he took damage from the thunder wave as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: He did succeed his constitution saving throw, but he took damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Billy whips out that thunder wave and revealed this creature to be directly in front of him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now the rest of you guys are still inside in the office at the back of the yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the first thing obviously that we're going to do here is roll some initiative.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: I am going to say with the thunder wave going off, pure coincidence perhaps or maybe just an epic cinematic moment, but rain begins to fall on the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: relatively rare that you get rain here, but a storming sort of rain begins with the thunder clap going off just to add some atmosphere.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you guys would hear this thunder wave go off.
[SPEAKER_02]: And no, it's not thunder.
[SPEAKER_02]: Although it sounds kind of like thunder.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like thunder if thunder was on the ground, you know, at the other end of the yard from you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let me turn this over to battle and then we can also I'm going to put us on this map where much to [Lark]'s delight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sure there is actually a battle map because it is relatively important here the distances and things that are involved.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the center.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you might have to sort of zoom in and out.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, you're going like this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you've got the vista above and the actual tactical battle map below.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh no, why are we so far?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so Claring Bones Yard is 120 feet in full distance, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are in the office here.
[SPEAKER_02]: roughly sort of 100 feet or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't have line of sight until you walk out of the office as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy is right here next to the creature, then this is the road which is 20 feet across and then these are all buildings and stuff on the right hand side that is inaccessible here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me put on the turns and you can roll some initiative as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because I think we heard everyone heard the thunder.
[SPEAKER_00]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you guys heard something go off.
[SPEAKER_03]: I actually rolled good initiatives for once.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the creature rolled, and I rolled earlier.
[SPEAKER_02]: And just to prove that I am not lying, there's my natural 20 for the creature.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he rolled a 22.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they're all going to go first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, because I guess that's quite important in this scenario.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, but Billy already had a turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you know, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just to note as well, this guy here is the delivery man who is fully dead, but this driver over here is just unconscious and will make death saving for us, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you would expect, if that is relevant to you in any way.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you're also natural 20, for example, he might be back up and in the fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: as an additional combatant.
[SPEAKER_05]: And do I see directly the steam bun or?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, Shepard.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shepard is incapacitated and cannot help you in this fight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shepard may help you, although you don't actually have any control over him as a construct, but he is just physically there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I just put him on the map for that reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it is going to be the creature's turn first.
[SPEAKER_02]: It kind of like jumps down off the wreckage of the carriage, moves five feet towards Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: It will take a hit on you, Billy, first off, as you would expect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would I expect that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, he seems aggressive.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in fact, you can make an insight check before anything else happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Insight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, you're just scared shitless at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: This huge thing has just jumped down off the wreckage of the cart.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were obviously not expecting to see it there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so you don't have any clue what is really happening here, other than this thing is right in front of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It jumps down and is going to attempt to hit you with, I whispered that, but it's a 12, which I assume doesn't hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do have 12 AC.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it does hit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Unless you wanted anything about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I would love to do something about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: You don't have any shields or anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do have shield.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that work?
[SPEAKER_02]: Shield is a reaction and will plus five to your AC.
[SPEAKER_07]: So that's around until it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if it had multiple attacks, for example, it's going to affect all the attacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, let's do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, shield up.
[SPEAKER_02]: The first huge slam comes down and is actually not aimed particularly well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you managed to pull up a shield, block the attack from this creature.
[SPEAKER_02]: It will try again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, do you have magic search every time you just use a spell slot, then I roll a 20.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, and only on a 20.
[SPEAKER_05]: I have to roll on the table.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, so it's just unlikely.
[SPEAKER_05]: But if I use the tides of chaos, yeah, to give myself advantage, then I immediately roll.
[SPEAKER_05]: The next one immediately happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, unfortunately, you're about to get crit, which is going to be rough for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, we go a level three sorcerer.
[SPEAKER_05]: Jesus, fuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: Is it permanent?
[SPEAKER_07]: Instant death?
[SPEAKER_05]: If it doubles my health...
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just kill off a character like... Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, well, I guess he's dead.
[SPEAKER_03]: I have 23 health.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm afraid with 23 health.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm putting!
[SPEAKER_07]: No!
[SPEAKER_00]: It was nice to see you.
[SPEAKER_07]: It was a good session.
[SPEAKER_07]: And we are so far away from even reacting.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can't do anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: We will see what happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, Billy is smashed with 52 points of damage, which is insane.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's so high rolls on the damage dice as well for that crit.
[SPEAKER_02]: um i really cannot do anything excellent um yeah you just get smashed to the side billy it completely ignores you after doing that and walks forward its full movement which is an additional uh 55 feet like this goes straight through here and uh leaves you
[SPEAKER_02]: potentially dying on the ground, potentially dead on the ground, we will find out.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest of you guys hear the sound and ask it, it is your turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just saw Billy got completely smacked by this guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You haven't seen anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah, I haven't seen anything yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cause the door is closed here.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you are about to open the door to see this thing coming towards you at speed.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Billy crumpled on the ground.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, yeah, I guess, uh, it's going to be, yeah, I'm going to walk to the door and open it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You walk over to the door, you open it up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's five feet of movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, you open the door up and you just see this thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's kind of like, I mean, it moves fast, but it's not running.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, it's like stomping forwards at speed, big strides through straight through the middle of everything and just knocking stuff left and right without any particular.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it seems directed towards you guys now.
[SPEAKER_02]: It seems to almost know where you guys are, or at least what its goal is.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I see this thing walking towards us.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, well, I quickly turn back and say, oh, shit, guys, there's a big, there's a really big metal construct walking towards us.
[SPEAKER_03]: Be careful.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just, I don't, do I see Billy now?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or do I not see him?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I guess not.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, it's all focus right now is on this huge creature stopping towards you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So yeah, I see him and he's walking towards us and I am going to cast.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to cast heat metal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, it automatically activates it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure if that's supposed to happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think it automatically happens, and it has to make a save to not take the full damage or something, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's see.
[SPEAKER_03]: What does it say?
[SPEAKER_03]: Detail.
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me put it in the chat.
[SPEAKER_03]: There we go.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's what I wanted to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this creature is half made of metal, so pretty good to be able to choose a metal object.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: What particular part of it are you choosing?
[SPEAKER_03]: The part that's holding the burning thing in the middle, heart.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's heart, basically.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because it's a metal, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not going to be able to remove that, obviously, which is pretty bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So any creature physical contact takes 8d8 when you cast the spell so it just straight away takes 8d8 like there's no 2d8 2d8 so that's 16 damage 16% damage cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you hear it kind of roll with pain as this happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if the creature is holding or wearing the object, takes damage from it, the creature must exceed a constitution saving throw or drop the object if it can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: It can't, so it's not going to make the constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: It will just have disadvantage on attack rolls and ability checks until the start of your next turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I did this before, you might have survived.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, you're next.
[SPEAKER_03]: We will see.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then...
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, anyway, really good because it basically, this happened in the other campaign as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: We just stopped making creatures that have embedded metal because heat metal just fucking stops them so hard.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's disgusting.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's why I took it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know that like the constructs will be metal.
[SPEAKER_03]: So yeah, I'm going to use my movement to
[SPEAKER_03]: Back up a little bit and then I.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then I wait, is it still in range?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, it's not in range.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK, never mind.
[SPEAKER_03]: And that's my turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm called it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think reacting to the thunderstorm and then probably seeing Ayaska's reaction when he opened the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to cast Mage Armor on myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: So click.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now it's on.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, well, I can do pretty much anything else.
[SPEAKER_00]: So then I think I would go to the
[SPEAKER_00]: whatever window is on this side, so next to the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there's a window above the desk on that side, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And can I do some sort of arcane check on this guy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Especially when I see the glowing center of his chest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can make an arcanography check, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, I'm too panicked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, it is not anything like you've ever seen before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, this is definitely like leaning towards an engineering thing more than the kind of study of magic that you've ever dealt with.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, with a 10, you can't really tell much about what is happening here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and then I think seeing that thing, I think I would be or Calder would be a little bit
[SPEAKER_00]: frozen to the spot, so staying next to the window.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you have an action, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to do anything else.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mage Armor is an action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, Mage Armor is an action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then, all good.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will just roll a death saving throw for this guy.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's failure.
[SPEAKER_04]: Luck.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, first I go out to the door, walk half of my movement to do that, and open the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the door's already open because I opened it.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's the only way out anyway.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I see the huge thing, but do I see Billy behind him as a pile of meat?
[SPEAKER_05]: Make a perception check.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm in the trash.
[SPEAKER_05]: I am in the trash.
[SPEAKER_00]: Such a pool of blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll say with a 13 you can see, yeah, the crumpled body of Billy, but it's hard for you to tell him what state he's at at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's behind, you can just see him like kind of draped over some of the scrap as he was just basically tossed aside.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billy's in the trash where he belongs.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, the danger is imminent, and I think Larg just reacts to that, instead of like, holy shit, Billy's there, lying, and this creature's coming towards us, so she will run towards it.
[SPEAKER_07]: I used 50 movement, and then I used my second movement here.
[SPEAKER_07]: However, I honestly think I have to use my...
[SPEAKER_07]: I will use my action to dash.
[SPEAKER_07]: because I can't do anything from this far.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I'll just dash my movement.
[SPEAKER_04]: What was it?
[SPEAKER_07]: And I can't reach Billy and I don't have range spells or anything.
[SPEAKER_07]: Starts my turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: And it's in melee with the steam bun or which one was it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Shepard.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, yeah, technically, I think Shepard's probably just going to disengage and run away, but it's not a fighting thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm here and I just pull my quarter stuff in front of me ready to react.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I'm just like, Billy, Billy, because he's just laying there as a pile of meat.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's not moving on the ground over there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: Felix!
[SPEAKER_04]: I am going to walk outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: And do I recognize this creature?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not this creature, but you recognize the type of creature it is, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh god, not another one.
[SPEAKER_04]: Another one.
[SPEAKER_04]: I am going to cast Fesbee moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Radiant damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so it's silver.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is like moonbeam.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's no moon.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there's no moon.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is formed of just pure light from the ambient light that surrounds Parvo.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So each creature in it makes a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it makes a constitution saving throw straight away.
[SPEAKER_02]: in it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunately, it rolls out 24.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, it succeeds, but it takes half the damage, I think, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Successful Save the Creature takes only half as much damage and isn't affected by the shapeshifting blah, blah, blah stuff as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you can roll damage for that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, roll damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah, you did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's five by five.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I'll just put it in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: 15 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: This creature takes that as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shepard is going to disengage and flee.
[SPEAKER_02]: It has self-preservation instincts at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we'll just use its movement to flee away.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't really do anything to help.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, I'm going to say that it's going to flee this way and flee towards Billy, seeing Billy's body crumple on the ground there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you feel nothing except the darkness of the void of whatever is beyond the world here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it's a normal Tuesday for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah do you even know what to do with this yeah you are dead you are you are dead that is the rules the creature the rules are the rules the creature
[SPEAKER_02]: Fucked you up, good and proper.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for now, nobody else really knows, so you are just a crumpled pile of bones and limbs on the floor of this thing until somebody discovers you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm afraid there is nothing for you to do except...
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll grab some snacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: Contemplate your choices.
[SPEAKER_04]: What do you mean, what choices?
[SPEAKER_02]: He didn't have any choices.
[SPEAKER_02]: He attacked first.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh no, okay, he didn't attack first.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, he didn't.
[SPEAKER_04]: He was here alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the way the cookie crumbles, I'm afraid.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the creature is going to move five, 10, 15, 20, 25.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an Attack of Opportunity lock.
[SPEAKER_02]: you miss, unfortunately, 30, 35, 40 feet of movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: It can't quite get to Felix, but it is moving forward in a seemingly, as it passes you, Lark, as well, you can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 15, this thing clearly just ignores you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It just stomps straight past you because it's able to, and it is clearly heading for a different goal than kill everyone or whatever, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it's just, Billy was in the way, it couldn't walk past Billy, unfortunately, but it is able to walk around you and is heading in a straight line for the rest of the group, but it has clearly something in mind as it pushes forwards.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sadly, it is not in Melee.
[SPEAKER_02]: with Felix, because it might as well use this action to attack you anyway.
[SPEAKER_07]: But I just feel like watch out guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let me just see what this is.
[SPEAKER_02]: So okay, so it has disadvantage as well because of the burning heat metal of the central portion of it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, I just need to read what is this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, okay, this is, okay, yeah, now it works.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is gonna try and hit you, Felix, with this, but it rolls a 10, so it fails.
[SPEAKER_02]: But basically, in its right hand, it has a length of chain with a hook that it is throwing out that extra five feet to try and wrap around your leg, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you're able to kind of just like step out of the way and avoid that from happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: But ask it, it is your turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, yeah, I'm just going to still stay inside.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I am going to activate Dissonance Whispers.
[SPEAKER_04]: And he has to make a wisdom saving throw.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry, yeah, wisdom saving throw.
[SPEAKER_04]: Recast it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I just need to fix this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wisdom saving.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, not particularly wise.
[SPEAKER_02]: With disadvantage, 14.
[SPEAKER_03]: It succeeds because it's 12.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it takes a cast.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello?
[SPEAKER_04]: Damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it takes seven damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: And at the end of your turn, so as a bonus action, you can reactivate heat metal, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: I will reactivate it.
[SPEAKER_03]: So then I can just throw, I guess, a 28.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me see.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where do I do that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Heat metal.
[SPEAKER_02]: It kind of is really, really strong against things that can't move the metal.
[SPEAKER_03]: It is very strong.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, and since we're finding constructs, I'm like, yeah, I'm definitely going to play.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, two sevens on the d8.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do we see something in his chest?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, as it walked past you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think you see anything in particular, but you see like a green light is glowing inside his chest that is reminiscent to you of an essence core, like that's the kind of thing you would have seen before.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you don't see like a particular thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just more like you can see the cavity in his chest that's there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, I mean, it's taking some decent amount of damage here from these things that are happening, and it's got this advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anything else for you, Asuka?
[SPEAKER_02]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm just going to stay inside because Barge is in.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this thing is clumping its way towards you, Golda, as you see it taking some damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you see it whip out this chain towards Felix as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I will try to shoot it through the window with some chromatic orb.
[SPEAKER_04]: So let's see.
[SPEAKER_00]: First is spell slot cast.
[SPEAKER_00]: 24 hits, probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then... Yeah, 24 doesn't hit, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then he does 13 fire damage, but... Fire damage?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: I forgot always to use these moon things.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I have this feast, evocation adepts.
[SPEAKER_00]: When you cast an evocation spell, you can roll up to two of your unexpended hit points and add them to the damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I want to try that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if I click this, does it roll?
[SPEAKER_00]: And then another one.
[SPEAKER_00]: So in total it would be 24 fire damage and I aim it to be middle of the construct in the body.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I guess as you guys see that especially now with the new feet and you know just the eyes and the skin under the
[SPEAKER_00]: long sleeves start to glow more red-ish again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, this creature's looking relatively hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you guys are actually pumping up damage onto it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, it's looking relatively hurt.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: We did like a bunch of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else, Kolde?
[SPEAKER_02]: You back off into the corner.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I back off.
[SPEAKER_02]: As far as I can.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me make another roll for this guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, that's a success.
[SPEAKER_01]: Log.
[SPEAKER_07]: I can't use two magic actions in a turn, is that correct?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, no, you can't.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, if you have action search, you might.
[SPEAKER_07]: No.
[SPEAKER_07]: True.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I mean, you can use one leveled spell and then...
[SPEAKER_07]: It says, except the magic action.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, it does, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It depends what you're trying to do.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, I wanted to use two actions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can't use two actions at a time, regardless, unless you... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: I mean, I can if I use actions, but...
[SPEAKER_07]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: If I use my... Hey, I'm stupid!
[SPEAKER_07]: I can use my... No, I am wise, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Make up your mind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why are you so stupid?
[SPEAKER_07]: Wait!
[SPEAKER_07]: No, I used my action search this round to be able to dash and use a magic action.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll get to Billy.
Billy!
[SPEAKER_02]: And... How does he look?
[SPEAKER_02]: No medicine check necessary.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see that Billy lies cold and lifeless on the side of a pile of scrap.
[SPEAKER_02]: He basically took just one huge blow that seems to have like snapped his neck.
[SPEAKER_02]: His body is basically intact, but his neck is at a weird angle and his eyes are open and he appears lifelessly in front of you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, oh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, she gets traumatized, but I think she either way like reaches to him and she will attempt to cast healing hands on him and like take his head.
[SPEAKER_07]: Healing hands, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you pump.
[SPEAKER_02]: You flash back to a scene of you desperately trying to save Theo's life, having him bleed out all over you and pumping healing into his body to have no response.
[SPEAKER_02]: The same feeling as you pump or attempt to pump some healing into Billy and find nothing in return.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunately.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, oh, oh.
[SPEAKER_07]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I mean, that's my turn anyway.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think I'm just like holding his head like... Yeah, that's my turn.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh boy.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's the driver, like the guy who's alive there.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is bleeding.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's unconscious, bleeding out.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's not alive, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a magic action.
[SPEAKER_06]: I am going to move the first beam onto him again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: How fast can you move?
[SPEAKER_01]: 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does he need to make a save again?
[SPEAKER_01]: What was the save?
[SPEAKER_01]: The best beam was when the cylinder constitution saving for.
[SPEAKER_01]: When the spells area moves into its space, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Or was it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's working again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Working?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So another constitution saying, unfortunately, it is very constitutional.
[SPEAKER_02]: But with still disadvantage from heat metal, it fails on that, which is pretty nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: 11 points of radiant damage onto it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunately, it is not shape-shifted and doesn't revert back to its pre-constricted form.
[SPEAKER_02]: That would be cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, it takes a bit of damage as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can also make an insight check, since everybody else has been able to, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: On a 15 and above, I will give you
[SPEAKER_02]: Decent information.
[SPEAKER_02]: But with a 12, it's odd that it just ran past Lark and went for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But beyond that, nothing else you can glean from its actions.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Shepard walks over.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will move inside.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, sorry, go on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, move away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: How far do you want to go inside?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this should be like, so that's, there is like the back, if I just draw that there, there is like the back office here, but the door is like smashed open.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah, but there's like a bit of cover that you can have there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shepard goes over to Billy's body as well, and just like kneels down on two, two feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's kind of like just nudging Billy with the lamp as Billy's body is just,
[SPEAKER_02]: lifeless in the road in front of the gate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we don't need you on there anymore, Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: So the creature... Billy left the gate.
[SPEAKER_03]: In real life.
[SPEAKER_01]: The creature walks forward
[SPEAKER_02]: So it took damage already when the spell entered its face.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does it take damage if it starts its turn in this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because that would be crazy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Question.
[SPEAKER_02]: it just says when the cylinder appears yeah okay so it's not appeared so you just have to keep moving on to it to make it take damage yeah but it can now just leave it um sure um so five ten fifteen it will go this way uh and it's done there then if it ends its turn there okay 15 uh 20 it looks at you asker but disregards you 25 30
[SPEAKER_02]: 35.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is in melee with Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: In melee with you, Felix, it is going to attempt to hit you with this.
[SPEAKER_02]: It still has disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: It rolls a 10.
[SPEAKER_02]: It has two attacks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Of course it does.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see that it is like kind of trying to move, but it can't properly move its like muscles because of this burning ring of metal in the center, which is almost starting to melt.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like only like iron, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not, it's not that strong.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Felix is able to easily dodge out of the way as it is like throwing its hand forward, clearly trying to grab a hold of him, Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just a traumatizing skin, just imagining it like young, scary-looking kid just looking up at the giant monster and just instantly has his neck broken immediately.
[SPEAKER_03]: I cannot wait for the pic, for the image of this one.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think, unfortunately, I think this is going to not get past the moderation feature.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe just before the attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: But ask it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, uh, seeing that this thing completely ignores me, I'm just like, uh, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I say to Calder, I think he's programmed to specifically attack Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: He just walked past me.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know what happened.
[SPEAKER_04]: He just walked past me.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I am going to activate, let me see, I'm going to move back.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm going to activate Shatter.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm going to make sure that it doesn't hit Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so 10-foot spheres.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so it has to make a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunately, got some pretty good constitution, but disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Disadvantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, never mind.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, so it takes, let me roll the damage.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cast.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, there's no button for damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I guess I'll just have to... 3d8.
[SPEAKER_03]: It takes 7 damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pretty good, another 7 damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's starting to look pretty rough as you guys are just pummeling it with damage here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And because as a bonus action, I'm going to activate the damage part of Heat Metal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_04]: And it takes 13 damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, huge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And how's it looking now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, pretty hurt, pretty hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, it can't barely move because this heat metal is completely hitting it and you guys are just pummeling it with damage and it is, yeah, like you said, like a one-track mind kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys seem to be able to...
[SPEAKER_03]: I shout to Calder saying, he's looking really hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it is your turn, Calder.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is wall between me and him now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there was windows, if you remember the picture from before though.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can basically see in, let me just give you a quick look at it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, true, true.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's windows so you can see in if you need line of sight on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And actually it kind of stops its movement there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me see if I can... Jesus, why am I so slow?
[SPEAKER_03]: Everybody's slow, dude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I don't want to run there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess I'll just keep going.
[SPEAKER_00]: Chromatic orb.
[SPEAKER_07]: Can you see it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there's windows above the thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yeah, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will use it as second level.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come on, hit, fuck.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's my turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I make any, sorry, can I make any, any insight check or something or something that I would get any, any.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you haven't made an insight check yet, so you can make an insight check as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I haven't made one either.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, you guys can make one.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think you kind of have worked out this clearly focused on Felix here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But maybe more are we seeing any sort of cracks or something in the central piece or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's probably insight.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's probably just going to be perception.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, had to say from this point of view, especially because it's kind of got its front facing Felix, you can't even really see the front of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it looks very hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like you're just taking chunks of flesh off and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it looks very hurt in that respect.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can't see much more than that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, like you are holding on to Billy's body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't forget to change your name to Lee.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think she has a hard time just leaving him there, but either way the monster just ran to the other.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I think she just starts running after it.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think she pulls Billy to the side, on top of the rubble, I think.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just not leaving him on the gate.
[SPEAKER_07]: And she's like, I'm back Billy!
[SPEAKER_02]: I pull him off to the side, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll just throw him back then.
[SPEAKER_07]: And use my action to dash.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I'm here.
[SPEAKER_07]: Lark's doing what she would do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, that's all you can do right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Felix.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think I see Felix through the window here if Calder was also shooting from the room.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah, there was room, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I am going to cast Flameblade.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh shit, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So the first beam will disappear.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, yeah, fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you're like pinned.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my God.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are dodging blows left and right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whilst you try and pull the flame blade out and kind of turn fire, so to speak, but you are not able to hit with a natural one, I'm afraid.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Anything else on your turn, Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK. No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: On Shepard's turn, Shepard is going to hook its lamp head around Billy and start dragging him alongside back towards Lark on the road itself, just pulling the limp body of Billy behind it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billy Cosplay.
[SPEAKER_02]: The creatures once again, still with disadvantage, attempting to grab.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh my goodness.
[SPEAKER_02]: He uses natural twins.
[SPEAKER_02]: the heat metal is absolutely deleting it and it is just smashing into the wall with this huge arm like it's trying to get past like just trying to grab a hold of Felix and he can't even do that and this small confined space it's burning it's being attacked from all sides it's looking pretty rough um so uh that's all it can do annoyingly so ask it uh uh yeah i am going
[SPEAKER_03]: uh let's see I am going to move here and taking a page from Billy's book I am going to activate Thunderwave
[SPEAKER_03]: So he has to make a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is a 15 foot cube, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, 15 foot cone.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's like a cone.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was just checking.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not going to throw a load of papers and shit all over Golda and Felix, but not actually damage them, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So on a failed save, it takes damage and gets pushed 10 feet away.
[SPEAKER_02]: But let's see if it fails its constitution save.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus, it did use all its 20s to kill Millie.
[SPEAKER_02]: And with that, yeah, with that damage then, so 2d8.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is on its last legs as you throw it towards the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will say that you are trying to move it
[SPEAKER_02]: You are trying to move a 10 foot in this direction and it's going to hit the wall immediately.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can roll another D6 of damage as it crashes into the wall with force here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think probably breaking a bit of a hole in the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: Another three points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is looking on its last legs.
[SPEAKER_02]: It kind of is like trying to pull itself up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clearly, despite all of this is happening, it doesn't once turn its head to look at you, Asuka, with all this damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is just laser focused on trying to grab a hold of Felix, which it is struggling and failing to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: And it's good that it's on its last leg, because I am going to use my bonus action to activate the metal.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine damage is not enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see it drop to one knee as the burning kind of the iron
[SPEAKER_02]: iron circle around whatever is holding it apart is like literally melting from this like constant heat of the metal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just a quick question Grimton, because does thunder do any more damage to it or is it just like normal damage?
[SPEAKER_03]: You didn't notice any additional damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay we didn't notice anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay cool and then like I see this and I'm like Calder he's almost dead!
[SPEAKER_03]: Just hit him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just hit, bro.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Colde.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and with that motivation, I run just below him and hit with my dagger.
[SPEAKER_00]: Haha, not really.
[SPEAKER_00]: I run next to Eska and then I will cast... What is it called?
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic Missile, because that will for sure hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very good, very good.
[SPEAKER_00]: But wait, I want the level...
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, how does this work?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 1d4 plus 1 as many times as you want, as you do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, so I need to individually... Yeah, roll the damage three times, because you can shoot at three different people or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I see.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I want to catch you don't need to because I will let you keep the second level spell slot.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can just use a level one spell slot because you throw the first magic missile.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is literally on its last legs and you blast that that magic missile.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you want to defeat this creature called it?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think because he's on the one one nail.
[SPEAKER_00]: So now the head is also a little bit lower.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would say the air.
[SPEAKER_00]: on his side and I would want to try to aim just to air so that, you know, I would get.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think it's yeah, it's still looking at Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hit it in the fleshy side of its head.
[SPEAKER_02]: It goes through the ear and the metal just like cranks and like doesn't break because it's just a magic missile.
[SPEAKER_02]: But like you see the kind of like explosion like inside its skull as it slides forward, collapses in front of you, Felix, and is
[SPEAKER_02]: killed i'm gonna roll one more d20 for this driver just to see if he fails this he's dead so that's not really important but uh he's not dead right now um with that the threat is killed and combat ends um you guys what the fuck is that you don't want to know
[SPEAKER_07]: What?
[SPEAKER_07]: You know?
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, I don't ask that, I run to the door.
[SPEAKER_07]: Guys, Billy is dead!
[SPEAKER_07]: Billy is dead!
[SPEAKER_07]: Wait, what do you mean dead?
[SPEAKER_07]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: And I just like yell that through the door and then I run back to Billy, towards Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: At this point, yeah, Shepard has kind of also dragged his body closer towards the room for you guys as you head out.
[SPEAKER_07]: Put this sad music away instantly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys rush out to see Billy's body crumpled, being dragged along by Shepard, unmoving, just bouncing off the pieces of rubble as you get there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark has said that he's dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you guys want to do in this scenario?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Calder would first look at Felix, that Felix is okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Standing over there and then... Felix didn't take a hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I think Calder would also start to rush outside next to Billy after Trollarch.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Eska would probably do the same.
[SPEAKER_03]: First check on Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: Felix, you okay?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because of course he sees all the...
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm okay, for now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, well, that's good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, and I guess Eska would go outside too and check on Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you all gather around Billy's body.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anyone want to do a medicine check?
[SPEAKER_01]: You are welcome to do so.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: The sad music.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eska pulls out his lute and starts playing some sad music.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys gather around and yeah, Calder, I think you are first to realize that he is not breathing.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is no pulse.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see that his neck is bent in a way that is not good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you can make for me an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_04]: With a 16 you think about the
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Billy's dead body in front of you, but he has only been dead for 10, 15 seconds, something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there is a reanimated corpse in the office that is now no longer animated.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you wonder if there's perhaps something you can do for Billy if you are quick.
[SPEAKER_06]: I will go to the creature and try to get the essence out of him.
[SPEAKER_07]: What are we going to tell his family?
[SPEAKER_07]: He has such a nice mom.
[SPEAKER_06]: Get his body inside.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's head inside.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys head inside where it is a mess, despite you guys tidying out previously, it is now smashed apart by a thunder wave and there is a corpse on the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, there's two corpses, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: The body of the creature is clumped in the circle.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's slowly steaming as the heat metal finishes off and
[SPEAKER_02]: You can rush over to it, Felix, and take a look at the core.
[SPEAKER_02]: Embedded in his chest is a core much like your own.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this creature was clearly once or is
[SPEAKER_02]: Or I will get you to make a check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's do it properly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a medicine check on this dead creature.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are welcome to do something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix tells you to bring the body inside if you guys want to go over and help Felix, if you guys want to go and do anything in the scenario.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix seems to have a bit of a plan at least.
[SPEAKER_03]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eska is going to go check out the construct because he
[SPEAKER_03]: wants to know what the hell the thing is that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you can make me just ignore him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an engineering check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, engineering.
[SPEAKER_02]: Insane.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 23, like this is nothing that you've ever seen before.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you understand the concept, which is the idea that some someone has taken a
[SPEAKER_02]: a dead body, basically, and reanimated it using an essence core, obviously fixing some of its deficiencies, which seems to have some way benefited it or empowered it, but obviously also was not a pleasant process.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would ESCA also, in terms of like the same on the same line as Felix, recognize that they could do something for Belly or not?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you have no experience of this being a thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've never heard of it being the case, but you are seeing and you are seeing the existence of it here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is the first time you've ever seen anything like this, but you could probably be like, well,
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's a long shot, but kind of thing, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, maybe there's a chance.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess I would ask Calder, like, Calder, do you have any form of reanimation spells or anything that could help build a midi?
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, no, not that, not a single one.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I think, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, go ahead, go ahead.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I think Calder, I already sent some messages during the fight about the idea, but yeah, like I think Calder would... We're not metagaming.
[SPEAKER_03]: Metagaming!
[SPEAKER_00]: talking about, yeah, or thinking some idea that, okay, maybe, maybe we saw this thingy coming in alive, undead alive, and then we'll just learn that Felix is also having this inside him.
[SPEAKER_00]: And after three years, and I mean, Felix so far looks somewhat
[SPEAKER_00]: Human, still, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Somewhat human.
[SPEAKER_02]: It can't be that bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just before you continue, Felix, you can just make a, I don't want to keep getting you to make the same checks, but I think it has to just be another engineering check, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, it's not your area of expertise.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know much more about what is going on with you than anybody else in the room does.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So anyway, sorry.
[SPEAKER_07]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you mean that Mr. Felix, you have you have died before and this was put after you died?
[SPEAKER_04]: Was alive.
[SPEAKER_06]: But that's that's only this only thing I know.
[SPEAKER_06]: I was sedated for three years almost.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can discuss the details maybe later.
[SPEAKER_00]: You were alive, Billy has barely passed away.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's still warm, so maybe, I don't know what the fuck they did to you, but can we somehow
[SPEAKER_00]: reverse engineer this and I'm starting to create Biliam into the table.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would want to start, you know, prepare Bili for whatever operation this would be.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, Eska is nodding his head like, yes, that is what I was suggesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm afraid I have no knowledge or experience in any of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, I
[SPEAKER_02]: suggests that this might be a last resort in order to revive uh billy right here so yeah you guys pull billy up onto the side felix barely knows anything more than you guys but he is at least able to at least kind of uh explain something i think felix you remember that uh
[SPEAKER_02]: The fact that it worked on a living person was especially special, let's say.
[SPEAKER_02]: And perhaps on a dead person, it is easier to do, but there is potential risk behind doing that.
[SPEAKER_02]: What we're going to do is, of the four of you, three of you can make death saving throws for Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I will three of you can decide to make that saving froze and you will make them one by one and I will, I will say to the group.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, because as I always say, okay, so let's try and
[SPEAKER_03]: do whatever, and then the two people who join him, he'll grab the shoulders and he'll be like, let's hope for Billy that this works, and he'll use two bardic inspirations.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: If this ends up being a 2-2, 2-2, no, it can't be 2-2 if three of you roll, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: It can be a 2-1, in which case the fourth person will need to roll, and then if it's a 2-2, one more of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll have Billy roll the fifth one to make it.
[SPEAKER_02]: If it comes out 2-2, Billy can roll the final one.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if it goes 2-1, then whoever's the fourth person will also have to roll, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: Mr. Felix, do we need to pump some energy into it or anything like that?
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know what we have to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's got energy enough of itself, so... Yeah, before you roll...
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, basically, you guys don't have any idea really what you're doing here, or what potential ramifications this might have to Billy, but obviously, it's better than him being dead, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: The core, as you pull the core out, it's still hot and the iron is actually still soft.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whoever is going first is the person that is basically going to cut Billy open, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So whoever of you decides to do that, you are going to roll first.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can volunteer for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I feel like I would have read some, well, yeah, I mean, just reading, et cetera, et cetera, sealing those skeletal structures in the institution or college or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: So if nobody else wants, I guess Calder would volunteer.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess it would make sense if like, if Eska, Felix and Calder do it, because they're the three with the knowledge of this thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: It wouldn't make sense for Lark to do it, because she has like zero knowledge of any of this.
[SPEAKER_02]: What this means is if you three don't succeed, Lark is making the fourth one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, obviously.
[SPEAKER_03]: If two of you fail and one of you succeed, Lark is making the fourth one.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess Eska would go up to Felix and Carla and be like, okay, let's do our best to try and help Billy and then he'll give both of them bardic inspiration.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Koldy, you approach the body.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a medicine check.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not going to affect anything, but you can make a medicine check just to see.
[SPEAKER_07]: But guys, I have luck though.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have luck.
[SPEAKER_02]: You might need it.
I have luck!
[SPEAKER_02]: I need it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You might need it if you're the if you're the yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is a medicine check colder.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are like you kind of know where the heart is.
[SPEAKER_02]: You kind of understand the anatomy of someone and you have a knife or something or you have a tool of some kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have one small...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if that would be a dagger or something, but something.
[SPEAKER_03]: Otherwise I have a dagger, so you can use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also got a dagger.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also got a flameblade.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think that might be too much damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: It might be a little bit more difficult to control.
[SPEAKER_02]: You step up to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, and yeah, you can describe for me what you, how you do it and also roll your first dice, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think, I think it, I mean, seeing how the construct is in the, or was in the, seeing how this thing was in the construct.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do I also see,
[SPEAKER_00]: this thing in Felix's chest right now, or is it covered by... That's up to Felix, if Felix wants to show you how as a comparison.
[SPEAKER_02]: None of you guys have seen this before, he's only told you about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's inside of me, mine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Middle, right, left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just where normally your heart is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so as you open up, I think you can see a big scar much like a pacemaker scar or something like that that someone would have over their heart.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you guys can actually see that there's a very faint greenish glow under the skin.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for Felix, it is like embedded and then sewn back up in a pretty
[SPEAKER_02]: It's sewn back up in a pretty clean way to not show as much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think Felix already told you that they replaced his heart.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, true.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that in mind I think Calder would start to make like two straight cuts, so one first vertical and one horizontal that you know, might be a little bit graphical, but you know then the skin can be like peeled so that it's a square shape.
[SPEAKER_00]: But trying to
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Calder would be trying to look this as, you know, just turning the emotional part away and thinking this as an academic mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: So starting to operate it that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can't wait for the AI image of this one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Before you roll, I will say natural ones and natural 20s will count.
[SPEAKER_02]: On a natural one, you can still use bardic inspiration, but it will be
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean, it's impossible.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you can't make it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't make it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's irrelevant anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: But an actual one will, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's 1d20, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just 1d20, please, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: But your body's a d6, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's a d6, so that's not going to help.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there is nothing that can be done here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder is butchering Billy as best as he can.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he is not a surgeon, not an open heart surgeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: He doesn't have to worry about the patient's lifestyle.
[SPEAKER_02]: He doesn't have to worry about the patient's life signs necessarily, but he still has to do his best.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he is trying his best to do this as he opens up Billy's chest cavity, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, I think Asuka or Felix, one of you guys is actually removing the core from the
[SPEAKER_02]: construct trying to keep it as intact and usable as possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: So whichever one of you wants to do that, you can take a step forward, tell me how you're doing that and then roll your d20.
[SPEAKER_03]: Probably me then.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think it makes more sense for Felix to do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you look at this thing and you see this almost like mirror image of you Felix, but obviously in a much worse way, what you could have been perhaps as you lean forward the melted iron around the core of this creature visible.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just trying to very carefully trying to just get it out.
[SPEAKER_04]: Please go ahead and make your roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good job.
[SPEAKER_00]: One for one.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we get in the situation where Lark comes to roll as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do we need three?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you are definitely going to be rolling luck for success or failure, but not yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: As Asuka is now tasked with attempting to install this, having no previous knowledge, obviously, of what that might mean.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you understand engineering, you understand cause, you understand the principle of linking essentially a energy
[SPEAKER_02]: you're essentially replacing the life force, however you might describe that, of a human being with magic.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this is something that has never been done before, as far as you know, has never been thought to have been able to be done.
[SPEAKER_02]: And from what you understand from Felix, perhaps Billy being dead in this scenario is what might make it work.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, please.
[SPEAKER_07]: Alleluia, praise the god we have.
[SPEAKER_02]: The concept is simple enough for you, Asuka, in that this is like working on any kind of construct or engineering machine.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just need to forget about the fact that you are doing surgery on this 19 year old kid and treat it like a machine, which you are able to do focusing yourself in and connecting essentially the heart into like, you basically remove Billy's heart is no longer pumping blood anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: and replace it with an essence core designed already, luckily, to replace the life force, the beating heart of a creature with a core.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, I would like you to roll five times on the sorcery, the wild magic table, please, as this happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, sir.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's see if I can do it like this.
[SPEAKER_01]: One, two, three.
[SPEAKER_01]: We might have to resolve them.
[SPEAKER_07]: They're gay.
[SPEAKER_07]: What do you mean damage?
[SPEAKER_01]: Damage.
[SPEAKER_07]: What does it mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are, this is not damage, luckily.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, all right.
[SPEAKER_07]: Tell us what they are.
[SPEAKER_02]: We all die around you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, potentially, there is some bad results on this table.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, this is so perfect, though.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. With 87, up to three creatures of your choice that you can see within 30 feet take 1d10 necrotic damage.
[SPEAKER_05]: you gain hit points equal to the sum of the necrotic damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So immediately as the body starts to convulse on the table, you guys feel your essence being sucked out of you just from being purely in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'll say because Lark wasn't involved in the directly in the surgery.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll make it the other three of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys can take 1d10 Necrotic Damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: That is basically sucked out into Billy to replenish his missing life force, which is very perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Roll the dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: But that is so cinematic, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll just use this.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: What's the next one?
[SPEAKER_05]: Next one is 48.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, you and up to three creatures you choose have the invisible condition for one minute.
[SPEAKER_05]: It will end immediately after it makes an attack roll, deals damage, or casts a spell.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Lag, you see everybody kind of flicker in and out of existence for a second, as basically the Essence Core starts to react with Billy's innate.
[SPEAKER_02]: magic and there is like sparks and explosions and at first people start to get like their life sucked out of them and then they start to flicker in and out of existence until they disappear completely in front of your eyes uh yeah sorry i i am i am resistant to necrotic damage so i only take three damage yeah all good uh what's the next one please billy
[SPEAKER_07]: So they all disappeared in front of my eyes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, but this is happening like bang, bang, bang.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's like really, really quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it may just immediately be removed or who knows.
[SPEAKER_05]: 14.
[SPEAKER_05]: Creatures have disadvantage on saving throws against the next spell you cast in the next minute.
[SPEAKER_05]: That involves a saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't do anything in this case.
[SPEAKER_05]: 21.
[SPEAKER_05]: For the next minute all your spells with a casting time of an action have a casting time of a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think spells are like magic and spells are just like shooting out of Billy's body.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're flickering back into like visible and invisible visible invisible as all this is happening and there was just like a cracking explosion of essence magic.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then finally, with a 33, you have resistance to all damage for the next minute.
[SPEAKER_05]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, they are flickering in and out of existence as invisibility goes off, as sparks of magic explode out of Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: But eventually, you guys get to,
[SPEAKER_02]: a point where after you know 30 seconds or so things start to die down like you are watching this happen until they kind of phase back in almost into existence around the table in the positions that they were when all of this happens.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyone who has healing magic probably needs to use that to suitor up Billy's open chest cavity as this is happening, because you are watching Billy convulsing on the table with a mixture of magic and just general shock and trauma.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because I'm operating on him and I finish, I'm going to cast Healing Hands right away.
[SPEAKER_03]: That will also cost the Healing Hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, all of you start to put your like radiant ailer magic into him and start to like suit up his chest wound, which heals you up.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then Billy, you are healed up for 19 points of damage and you take a breath.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not unconscious anymore because he's been healed.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_07]: And conscious.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, conscious.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think you immediately take a huge breath, Billy, and you're in an incredible amount of pain.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your neck is still at the wrong angle and you kind of pop it back into position as all of this happens.
[SPEAKER_04]: Should I roll for you?
[SPEAKER_02]: You look up to see a bloody Colder, Asker and Felix surrounding you and looking down on you as you are suddenly in the office.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you probably see the heart, you know, in one of our hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think Colder is holding your heart.
[SPEAKER_06]: Welcome back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you alive?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can you breathe?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: You recognize us?
[SPEAKER_07]: You're normal.
[SPEAKER_07]: You're not like monster.
[SPEAKER_04]: Monster?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, hi.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, where am I?
[SPEAKER_03]: What happened?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're in the office, Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, seeing, you should see Eska just going like, oh, fucking hell, with bloodied hands and everything.
[SPEAKER_03]: And he's just, it looks like he's exhausted and he's like, well, welcome back to life, I guess.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're at the office.
[SPEAKER_07]: And the body of the thing is like at the corner, I think still.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, just probably slumped over.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now a huge hole in its chest cavity where you removed the thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think you still have hold.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or you have in your possession what is more like a bucket almost like bucket sized the previously had the small lessons core floating inside inside this creature to presumably give it like more energy more power it's some kind of like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dynamo that increases the essence power, but that wouldn't have fit in Billy's chest.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've just kind of pulled out what looks essentially to you guys in the amount of time that you had to do all this regular essence core, but clearly some thing has been changed or edited with it because I think you guys know that
[SPEAKER_02]: If this was a commonplace thing, this would be happening all the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyone who died would just get full essence cord and back up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys have probably achieved something that is pretty miraculous.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will say that without the natural 20, there would have been some severe repercussions to Billy as a result of this.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, being able to properly
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, seemingly basically invent the way of inserting the device into Billy in this way has at least managed to connect.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, how this affects Billy moving forward will be determined.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for now, Billy, you feel okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But as you kind of like move yourself around, you have a weird feeling that you just don't have a heartbeat.
[SPEAKER_02]: A familiar feeling.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, can I make some, I don't know, some check to see like, does William them look much more pale than usual?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because I mean, the color usually comes from blood and if it's
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not circulating anymore then.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's just got to be a medicine check again called it here.
[SPEAKER_02]: as you're trying to like work out what is happening here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you don't understand how this is working, but you suspected that somehow the essence core is now pumping the blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he still has blood pumping around him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He just doesn't have a heartbeat because now the core itself is the thing that is powering.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like what you didn't know about Felix potentially and
[SPEAKER_02]: No heartbeat, but still a pulse and still blood and still bleeds if cut and everything like that because You are the blood is still being pumped around just instead by a different source than a heart essentially like a pacemaker or something like that You just don't have the like pumping of the heartbeat anymore That's just gonna ask Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Billy and he looks skeptical like so, how are you feeling?
I
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm really confused.
[SPEAKER_03]: As am I.
[SPEAKER_03]: As am I, I must admit.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're confused with?
[SPEAKER_03]: And I guess, I guess, Eska would explain to Billy what he did.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so like, in order to revive him, we had to
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, we discussed, we saw the construct, and then we used the essence core to basically revive him.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Asuka, by some miraculous reason, maybe probably due to all of the stress surrounding him, for some reason, perfectly surgically inserted the... An Iron Man now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Prove that Billy now has a heart.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, talking about the heart, I think Calder would then give the heart to Biliam.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess this is yours.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, as Kestrel explained.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, well, yeah, this is a bit much, but basically, yeah, unfortunately, we saw this as the only choice we had in the moment to revive you.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, he just looks at the heart like, geez, don't have to give it to us.
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you mean revive me?
[SPEAKER_05]: I wasn't dead, I was just knocked out, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: You were dead.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, it's not possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you feel anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did it feel like a dream or sleep?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you see darkness or light?
[SPEAKER_05]: I did see some form of light.
[SPEAKER_05]: But it was like it was getting closer and I could feel the warmth.
[SPEAKER_05]: But then it was like it got taken away from me.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the light moved away.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then I woke up.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, well, for one thing, Billy, I'm glad you're here with us now.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then Eska, like,
[SPEAKER_03]: goes off and, I don't know, try to clean blood off his hands with... Well, luckily it's raining heavily outside, so you are able to basically walk out.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you do, after the stress of all of this, remember that there is a crushed cart and two dead bodies outside the yard that you may wish to do something about.
[SPEAKER_05]: I was going to say there's someone at the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it comes back to you as to what actually happened up to the point at which you were killed, but you kind of remember the events of the exterior of the yard.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, because I don't think anyone else knows that they're like other buddies except for Lark.
[SPEAKER_03]: She's the only one who went out there.
[SPEAKER_07]: So there was this card that you went to answer and then now the drivers are dead.
[SPEAKER_07]: They're on the ground, I guess.
[SPEAKER_07]: Maybe the creature killed them.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did you happen to see it before you got knocked out?
[SPEAKER_05]: I remember that one of them wanted to strike me with their club.
[SPEAKER_05]: But my magic reacted to it and blew them away.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then this creature came out of out of this art.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I guess at that point, Biddy has seen that that creature is lying there in the corner.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't remember much more.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, they brought it here.
[SPEAKER_07]: They attacked you and they brought it here, so they knew that it needed to be brought here.
[SPEAKER_07]: Why?
[SPEAKER_07]: How?
[SPEAKER_06]: Don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll go outside to the two persons and check if they're still alive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I rolled the third death saving throw for that guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is also dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: So both of the... Yeah, you walk out to see this kind of older man who is like broken on the ground, a broken cart, and then the driver who had his face kind of covered has been thrown a bit further as well and is also unfortunately bled out during the fight on the road.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an investigation check, Felix, if you wish.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you want to do anything else.
[SPEAKER_01]: If they've got any papers or something with them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You do find
[SPEAKER_02]: you find a fallen out of the pocket of the delivery man not the driver on the ground next to him in the rain on the cobblestone here you find a pocket watch however this pocket watch has been modified in some way and has a slight green glow to it and as you pick it up you feel that it has a magical aura to it but would need identification to be able to
[SPEAKER_02]: know what it is exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You also find a note on the delivery man as well, which is here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you find that note, you pick it up, you read it, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then what do you want to do with the bodies?
[SPEAKER_02]: And is there anyone else kind of heading out towards where Felix is?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Felix has like gone off, but...
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm just with Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I guess I'm just resting on the table.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Calder would also stay inside watching and taking notes about Billy writing them to the notebook, like step by step, what happened.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eska's too amazed that he actually manages it, so he just stands there staring into the rain, like holy shit, what the hell did I just do?
[SPEAKER_03]: He's just like, what did I do?
[SPEAKER_03]: These hands!
[SPEAKER_02]: These hands!
[SPEAKER_04]: I've created life!
[SPEAKER_04]: It is life!
[SPEAKER_04]: My creation!
[SPEAKER_03]: fucking dr frankenstein kind of shit does this mean eska is billy's new
[SPEAKER_05]: He's my mother.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'm his brother now.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're the older brother of the situation.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to direct the person's insight and then just lay them on the side.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You pull them in and kind of hide them away.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, we'll take a quick break there after that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And be right back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's the sad music back?
[SPEAKER_07]: Who's he gonna kill next, huh?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is this sad music?
[SPEAKER_05]: My bad, just a misplay on my part.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, don't die next time.
[SPEAKER_05]: Imagine if I was level 4, I wouldn't have died.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wasn't allowed to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Imagine dying to a guy that missed all of his hits on Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know, that's the worst part.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has a fucking double attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: He only needed one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it's insane because like heat metal actually does so much and it's just insane that it
[SPEAKER_03]: It gives you disadvantage on everything.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, it's so OP against Construct.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hey, don't talk about OP.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, Krimz is back.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not OP.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not OP.
[SPEAKER_05]: Should we buff it a little bit?
[SPEAKER_05]: Totally not OP.
[SPEAKER_02]: Disadvantage for one turn, but... No, it's... Well, it is for most things, because they just drop the armor piece or the item they're holding, but... Yeah, he can't drop this.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the other campaign, they fought a...
[SPEAKER_02]: dinosaur with a metal end on its tail, like a spike on the end of its tail, and they also had heat metal.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I was like, fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: I could have just not had the metal tail, but I thought it was cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then as a result, they fucking deleted this guy as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, it's a good spell for that very reason.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: I saw it and at first I didn't even realize, I didn't know we were finding constructs or anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I was just like, oh, this sounds cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to prepare this because people have armor all the time.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm like, oh, we're finding constructs.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Felix does the work,
[SPEAKER_02]: rain battering down as he drags the bodies of these two people still kind of relatively unknown to you guys, as he drags them back out or off the street and hides them away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anybody passing will probably just think that somebody has broken down, like broke their cart outside for now.
[SPEAKER_02]: and has gone to fix it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But there's a limited amount of time before people might start to come and investigate this situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, at least there's no bodies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Asuka stands outside washing his hands in the rain, kind of gazing out into the distance.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Billy sits on the desk with Lark and Colder as you recover from what has just happened.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will go back inside after I hit the bodies.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I mean, if nobody else is doing anything, as soon as Felix come back inside the building, then I think Calder would stand up and then start looking at Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think Felix would first share the stuff that he found.
[SPEAKER_03]: Unless you don't want to share, but like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll give them the letter, and well, the letter already says about the item, so I will also show the item.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you show the item, Felix, as you pull it out of your pocket, the needle of the pocket watch is pointing at you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: What if you...
[SPEAKER_00]: What if you put it closer to Billy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is the needle still... You move it closer to Billy and it's still pointing at Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if Billy is holding it, it's pointing at Felix.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think they were aiming for me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who's they?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think they want me back.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do I exactly know who the...
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's up to you and what you remember of your one on one session and stuff as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I can tell you what you at least found out was that.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, you don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think you ever identified the nature of the people who did that to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: Only saw a woman.
[SPEAKER_06]: You heard a woman's voice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You heard a woman's voice and a man's voice at one time.
[SPEAKER_02]: There was a man there as well that was talking sort of outside of your vision, but you only heard him once.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it did seem to be primarily this woman that was talking when you were there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you did not find out who they were.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know who it was, but I do know where it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you know where, so can you, can we, can we call a little bit back?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would say Felix that, I mean, you can tell me otherwise, but I would think in the time since you escaped, you and Theo may have either been back yourselves to that warehouse or sent people to go look at that warehouse and it was abandoned immediately.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you were able to return and find it, you know, abandoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: remnants of your imprisonment there or anything to do with you after you returned you probably would have given it a couple of weeks obviously at least or maybe sent someone who wasn't related or whatever but yeah unfortunately that is not a lead you can i mean you're welcome to go there but what i'm saying is you have already looked at looked into it and they don't seem to be operating from there anymore can you can you
[SPEAKER_00]: Tell us a little bit more.
[SPEAKER_00]: So what happened?
[SPEAKER_00]: You mentioned something like three years ago or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, four years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I point you, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I got brought there by my parents with also some kind of essence score.
[SPEAKER_06]: And after that I got sedated, so I don't remember much.
[SPEAKER_06]: I did woke up a couple of times.
[SPEAKER_06]: The first time was when my chest was still open, so I could still see the new essence in me.
[SPEAKER_06]: The second time it was already closed, but I was strapped to a chair so I couldn't see much, but there was a scratcher there that tried to help me free.
[SPEAKER_06]: But it was a bit too late.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then the third time I woke up again, I talked to a scratcher that got Theo there and then helped me out.
[SPEAKER_07]: Your parents bring you there.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did they sell you there?
[SPEAKER_04]: To be honest, I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have any
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know, several health issues or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Was this like last sort of option or?
[SPEAKER_06]: I had no health issues.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was more like I had no magic before.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you didn't have any magic before?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nope, nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then after that?
[SPEAKER_06]: Now I do, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I've mostly been trying to figure out how to handle all that magic.
[SPEAKER_06]: And what I can do.
[SPEAKER_06]: So lately I found out that I can heal and turn him into a scratcher.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I look at Peliam and I ask Felix still, do you think he can now turn into constructs?
[SPEAKER_02]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a history check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a history.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, we don't have like a regular history check, do we?
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's make it just an intelligence check, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You vaguely remember the woman who was talking to you, not talking to you, but talking around you when the couple of times that you woke up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think what the big difference is between you and Billy now is that they were able to do the procedure on you whilst you were alive the entire time and that seemed to be the fact that it worked at all seemed to be very surprising to them and they were very happy with the result of that working.
[SPEAKER_02]: Obviously with Billy having been dead when it was performed on him, he's probably closer to the type of creatures that you saw in that warehouse and that have now attacked this place here than he is to you, given the difference in the way the procedure is done.
[SPEAKER_07]: I wonder if they want you alive Mr. Felix or just thing inside you.
[SPEAKER_01]: They might want me alive to test things again.
[SPEAKER_03]: Aska picks up, may I see what your carry?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because he sees the item.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I see it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, show it to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_03]: This has an essence score in it.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it must be used as a checking device or something like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you trust me with it, I can see if I can find out more information about it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm saying this because Eska can identify the object, but he would need a long rest for it.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's why he's asking it now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, if I could have a look at it, I might be able to uncover more things from it and hopefully help us figure out things.
[SPEAKER_06]: Just hope there aren't many more of these, because then I'm definitely not safe.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you shouldn't be alone.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we should just not split anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, these sort of things are.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm sorry, Billy, that we even let you out there alone, because maybe we should have just been with you there.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm sorry we couldn't get to you so fast.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's okay, it's not your fault.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I guess I'm fine, so...
[SPEAKER_05]: It's, I think, what do I even look like?
[SPEAKER_05]: Do I see the essence core here or not?
[SPEAKER_02]: If you look down, you see like a barely healed big cross scar from where Calder cut into you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is a jagged, not surgical scar because Calder is not a surgeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have like a pretty nasty healing X of a scar over your heart.
[SPEAKER_02]: And underneath, much like Felix, you can see under your skin a glow of the kind of green of an essence core.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yours, I think, definitely looks more homemade than Felix's.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just due to the nature of the people doing it, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: But hey, we just did this in a couple minutes.
[SPEAKER_07]: They used like years.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, Billy is just kind of... And I think you just feel very drained as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And what you don't know, I guess, is how, if at all, it might affect your magic in any way, because you understand that Felix having a core does affect, or gives him magic basically, does having an essence core suddenly inside you affect your magic in any way and to what extent, et cetera?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like these are things you just don't know right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think William is even worried about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think he's still not sure
[SPEAKER_05]: how he's feeling because he's trying to grasp the idea of being dead and then revived with this essence score.
[SPEAKER_05]: And as he's not feeling his own heartbeat, he's not quite convinced that he's alive.
[SPEAKER_05]: More like he's still in some kind of a dream or a nightmare, I think, where he's still just trying to figure out if he's awake or not.
[SPEAKER_03]: Um, Krenzler, what time is it now?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think it's that late in the day, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, I mean, it was only like midday, basically, when when they went to open the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's, you know, half past noon, maybe, like, it's not been a long time.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, what's happened?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm just glad we didn't have to go to your mother to tell you're dead.
[SPEAKER_04]: That does seem
[SPEAKER_05]: Quite horrible news to receive.
[SPEAKER_07]: Let's make sure that never happens.
[SPEAKER_07]: So just don't leave our side ever again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll stay close.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess you'll have a sleeping party again.
[SPEAKER_05]: What do you mean again?
[SPEAKER_06]: As far as I know, Eska stayed with you, so.
[SPEAKER_07]: True.
[SPEAKER_07]: Don't think we're safe here either, no.
[SPEAKER_07]: Do you think?
[SPEAKER_07]: Guys, because now they're probably going to come looking for this cart and these people and this creature.
[SPEAKER_07]: At some point they're going to find the creature here without the essence core.
[SPEAKER_07]: They're probably going to be freaked out and mad, so maybe this is good.
[SPEAKER_07]: Wait, who even are they?
[SPEAKER_07]: What am I talking about?
[SPEAKER_07]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think any of us recognize them, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, only Felix has really looked over the bodies and he...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you don't recognize them, Felix, at all in any way, but you actually got a natural 20 on your investigation, Felix, so I will tell you based on that, alongside the things you found.
[SPEAKER_02]: that they are dressed in really conspicuously not aligned to any particular guild way.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you also know, Lark, especially, like, this is a job that the Portis Guild would do, delivering things normally.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would have expected those guys to be Portis Guild, like on a normal day, you would have expected them to be from one of the crews doing a delivery job, right, to deliver a crate somewhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: These guys were very clearly not wearing any Portis Guild stuff or any identification, as you would expect from someone who's actually doing something
[SPEAKER_02]: sneaky, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, so you don't find any identifying guild marks or anything that links them to a particular group of any kind, either.
[SPEAKER_07]: Felix, Mr. Felix, do you have any idea?
[SPEAKER_07]: about the people behind this, what kind of organization there could be, about the warehouse or anything like who owned that, who operated that or well I guess you don't.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have no clue.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did Mr. Theodore ever try to find that out?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think once you went once Theo helped you and set you up as a secretary after maybe a couple of weeks or a month or something you and him tried to do some investigations but as soon as you went back to the warehouse it's clear that they probably opt and left like the day after knowing that you escaped
[SPEAKER_02]: thinking that maybe you would be able to come back and find them they clearly like cleared out straight away and just left the place and potentially moved on to another place or who knows but you know obviously very secretive and not intending to you know not on the books in any way like in some abandoned warehouse yeah and where was this warehouse is it like anywhere in like some guild areas or something or
[SPEAKER_02]: It was in the core, not a particular guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it was just on the edge of the furlong in the core.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we might have to check other abandoned warehouses if there's something, might be something there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because they have a lot of stuff so they do need a big building.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the other thing that you know, Felix, from your time at the Guild of Engineers is that there would be property records for warehouses and these types of things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Clearly it wasn't being run as something, but presumably at some point it was.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it probably would have had an owner at some point as well, and maybe still does if you're interested in going down the route of trying to find any links in that sense as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should we discuss all the possible leads we now have and puzzle pieces?
[SPEAKER_00]: Try to figure out what is going.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, probably.
[SPEAKER_07]: Could we maybe meet in a tavern or something together so we can get maybe around people to a public place and have a drink and just discuss what we should do?
[SPEAKER_07]: I have some ideas.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can't go to the Plum and Bob because... No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, that's...
[SPEAKER_07]: There's plenty of taverns in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, and let's all make... Well, we shouldn't stick together because that would be too ambiguous.
[SPEAKER_03]: Five of us together.
[SPEAKER_03]: Would it be really though?
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, there are a group of people walking.
[SPEAKER_07]: Probably inside a tavern.
[SPEAKER_07]: We can cover up a little bit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, not in a tavern, but going to the tavern.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Should we maybe meet in a couple of hours in a certain tavern?
[SPEAKER_07]: I think I could go to Madame Rook now to ask if she has something new for me.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I actually have a suggestion about Madame Rook to you, Mr. Eska, once we meet.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have something in mind.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a possibility, yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I also could go to Mira and ask about Evan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Mira is, sorry, she's the leader of the brass line crew that I worked in.
[SPEAKER_04]: So... Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Question, Crimson.
[SPEAKER_03]: In order to change my spells, I need to have a long rest, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: So I can't do it like...
[SPEAKER_02]: As a bard, yeah, I think you have to sleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Different classes have different ways of changing their spells, but I think off the top of my head as a bard you have to prepare spells on a long rest, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there's like, most of them are like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then there's just a few, like I think a Warlock or something that can do it on short rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think the majority of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can also do some, I think one or two spells in the short rest.
[SPEAKER_07]: Did Billy level up?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, Billy leveled up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy was going to level up after that combat regardless.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, he had the worst time of it though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, next long recipe from a deaf experience.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ironman upgrade.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, probably.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so gained access to some extra abilities.
[SPEAKER_05]: Billy is kind of like looking down still at himself, like trying to figure out what happened to him.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then he's like, Whoa,
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I'm gonna need some new clothes.
[SPEAKER_05]: So everything is just cut open.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, just ripped apart.
[SPEAKER_07]: Maybe some shopping for you then.
[SPEAKER_05]: Red and bloody.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do I have clothes at home?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you have more than one pair of clothes for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could get clothes at home if you want or you can... Yeah, it's straightforward enough to go and buy some, but that's gonna cost you money obviously.
[SPEAKER_05]: I might need to go home and get some new clothes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so where do we meet?
[SPEAKER_07]: Let's decide some tavern that's like in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: But Crimson can't decide the name because we don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so taverns in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want one near like, for example, Salador Slip and that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then there is the Cobbler's Pot.
[SPEAKER_02]: cobbler's pot which is a very sort of working class like that area of the stacks in particular whilst the stacks is generally pretty lower class working class whatever that particular pub is is a kind of like busy place where lots of people come and go and is very sort of probably the type of thing you're thinking of when you want to be inconspicuous and yeah yeah
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess we'll...
[SPEAKER_03]: I think Eska would go back to the Plum and Bob just to rest.
[SPEAKER_07]: Again?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or just some other place that he can rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, there's other taverns that you know as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you probably know the Cobbler's Pot, but it's not the kind of place that would pay a lot for gigs from a bard.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's probably not somewhere you play regularly, which probably helps your cause in terms of keeping your profile as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can just head to a different if you want to rest up.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, you can't take a long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can only take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, Mr. Eska, actually.
[SPEAKER_07]: You could go have a relaxing bath at the cellar's slip and I was going to suggest later that maybe you could talk to Madame Rook as well because she might have something interesting to you as well.
[SPEAKER_07]: You're sort of like a power figure in a sense that
[SPEAKER_07]: You are an information that could be sold, but you are an asset to her in some way.
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, maybe not anymore, but still I think.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I think I'm only good as an asset to her if she controls me and can.
[SPEAKER_03]: can use me to gather other information or sell me out to somebody.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know how Madame Rook is.
[SPEAKER_03]: She doesn't do anything for free.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_07]: And maybe we should give her a chance because maybe she could be useful and we could trade information.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark, I like your enthusiasm and your kindness.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, if this Madame Rook is who you told me that she is, she will not
[SPEAKER_03]: give anything away for free so if I was to go up there and well basically kind of reveal myself she will know immediately who I am and I don't think I will leave that bathhouse unscathed I think you're wrong but of course you can do whatever you want again I thank you for providing options however
[SPEAKER_03]: Right now, this is an option that I cannot risk because I do not know what her intentions are and I do not know what she plans to do with me when she knows that I'm alive and well, literally in front of her.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that is a risk that I cannot take at the moment.
[SPEAKER_07]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm going to go and find her.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll find out her intentions myself.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, just be careful.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like I said, she is a very cunning lady and she does not expect to give out anything for free.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm not.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm giving something.
[SPEAKER_07]: Give me something.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: We just said that's not split up.
[SPEAKER_06]: I was just about to say that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's not split up now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who's splitting up and to where?
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, someone can come maybe with me or just near the Salvador slip if you want to, but I think I'm fine.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will go with you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Might need to birth, so.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, that's true.
[SPEAKER_07]: You can just go take a bath and we'll be in the same building.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: There's other things you can have there as well if you want.
[SPEAKER_07]: Anyway, what are you guys gonna do?
[SPEAKER_05]: I need to clean up and get some clothes and probably rest for a bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know a place where you can clean up.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hey, we can't all go to Stalder's sleep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_07]: I mean, I just don't want to be connected to you or Madame Rook right now if we think that we don't know what her intentions are.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll just go home for a bit.
[SPEAKER_07]: And someone has to go home with you then, like near, just watch behind, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: Stalder maybe?
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to, yeah, I can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But in that case, we would need to make a small tour.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need to go see if I have got the information letter that could, I don't know, enlight things for us.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK. We can go together.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, OK.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess it's Eska and then Billy and Calder and Felix and Lak.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's going to be the nice split.
[SPEAKER_02]: Smaller than previous splits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Getting there.
[SPEAKER_02]: One day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, so Felix and
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark head off to Salador's Slip, whilst the other three of you are going where in what order, basically, like where you're going first and then to where, if you're going to multiple places.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it depends on how I look, because I've been quite bloody, I assume.
[SPEAKER_02]: You all look pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rain will only clean so much.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've been in a fight in the rain, in mud, some of you were inside, but like,
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, all three of you look pretty rough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy's top is ripped open, and there is a recently healed scar underneath.
[SPEAKER_02]: So all three of you look pretty bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there any capes in this office or something that you know, working clothes or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there's probably some overalls or something like that, like aprons and things like that, that you could use to hold yourself up there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I did not mean to click that.
[SPEAKER_06]: How do you say that, but Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: Prestidigitation?
[SPEAKER_06]: Whoa.
[SPEAKER_05]: I leveled up.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_02]: Leveled up the ability to say prestidigitation, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what's the choice?
[SPEAKER_00]: So should we take the clutch from here?
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I don't know what is the best order.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should we first walk by the letter position and then go to Billy's home and then to the pub?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the pub is the final destination.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm not sure if we first should go to Billy's home and then to the letter.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think I can't really go into public looking like this.
[SPEAKER_05]: would have to go to my house first, even if it's a long walk.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's go back to the map and look out who's going where.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you guys, I guess it is Claring Bones.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's written Claring Bones everywhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't remember.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you came up with the name originally, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think I've just decided it's Claring Bones when you made a different name at the start.
[SPEAKER_02]: Either way is fine.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Claring Bones then.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I think it's written there everywhere else.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do we have the wiki where it says Shrepnel?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, Shrapnel is written as Claring Bold, B-O-L-D.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that is incorrect, but fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll just change that then.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, we'll go with Claring Bold, B-O-L-D, as that is his name in my sheet and everything as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it should be Bold.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys, at Claring Bold's Yard here,
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to head to Billy's home is actually kind of the closest place anyway, depending where else you guys are going, but.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess we could even walk together for a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you guys are all heading in the same direction, so you guys can go together, so to speak, until you get to the places where you need to split off.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you three are going to Billy's house first, so you guys start time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to split off?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So a three-way split.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, like I said, ask her, then Billy and Calder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I thought you meant ask him Billy and Calder, not ask him Billy and Calder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Asker wants some time alone because he still needs to, first of all, he wants to rest and second of all, he wants to just think about what just happened.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because, you know, he plays music for a living and now he's fucking reviving people and shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: So he's like,
[SPEAKER_03]: He's very, very confused right now and he needs time to...
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're just gonna go to a different tavern somewhere in the stacks?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you go to somewhere in the stacks, Billy and Calder go together to Billy's home, and Lark and Felix head to the slip.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess Billy and Calder, you guys probably arrive first as...
[SPEAKER_02]: the other's head towards the slip.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the middle of the day, so your mom's not going to be home, you have a key, so you can let yourself in pretty straightforwardly.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can get yourself cleaned up here, you can allow Colder to do so if you wish, but you guys both enter Billy's house and it's empty enough and yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I double check that nobody's home.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I just
[SPEAKER_05]: kind of start cleaning up and getting some new clothes.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'll tell Calder, if he needs anything, you can just feel at home.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I, I want to ask permission that, can I go through your father's things, like papers?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he have a work table over here or something?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think you can really find anything here because honestly, I've tried to look through his things, but he keeps mostly everything either on him or in his office.
[SPEAKER_05]: But you can check if you want.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, his room is over there.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I guess it's just a bedroom.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think he has like a working.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think he probably has a small desk, but he doesn't keep much work on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an investigation check though called and maybe you find something that believes not found before or is, you know, oversee overlooked.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I say also to Billy that, ah, but that is actually excellent idea that maybe we should try to go to his work office, office room in the, in the colleague at some point.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know where it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think maybe we could try to sneak in.
[SPEAKER_05]: What, what, what are you looking for?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't, I don't know, but I, I mean, he's somehow part of this all, no?
[SPEAKER_00]: So I have whatever puzzle clue that we can get, any connectors would be informative, probably especially related to the mysterious project that he's working on and he's not telling anything about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he's connected to Aiskar's father and
[SPEAKER_05]: He's for sure hiding something.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to make any acquisitions to your father, but it feels a little bit weird.
[SPEAKER_05]: He told me not to get involved.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he would only say that if he knows something about all this.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think it could be helpful to have more information.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think it's not going to be easy to get into his office.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I wouldn't risk it personally.
[SPEAKER_05]: But you might be able to do it since you are an official member of the college.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll think about it and I'll look up how it looks.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 24 called, are you looking through the desk?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're pretty certain there is like an absence of work here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like it doesn't look like he does any work here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't look like he's here very often at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't find anything, any files or anything that make any link to anything interesting for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and I don't remember this anymore, very exact, because I think it was multiple episodes ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: But was there also papers with the initials VV also over here?
[SPEAKER_05]: Something I saw and I probably I talked to it about.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: You mentioned.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I don't know if you mentioned that to Kolder or not.
[SPEAKER_05]: I know that Lark was, I think, listening.
[SPEAKER_05]: But I don't know if color was also there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I cannot remember anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would I see any papers with those?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, you wouldn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, specifically that was, I mean, you know, above table, but.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, Billy saw that in a specific place, basically that.
[SPEAKER_02]: was kind of hidden, I guess is what I'm trying to say.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not just blatantly open and available for anyone to look at.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so yeah, you guys kind of get cleaned up, change your clothes, et cetera here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, start to do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't take a short rest because I feel like Billy would at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can take a sit down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get some food, get some, like, have some lunch, take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Asker as well, you can also take a short rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just head back to one of the taverns and take some time for yourself.
[SPEAKER_03]: Asker is going to take time for himself, and before he heads out, he's going to disguise himself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, I misclicked.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to use a... Oh, but the apply thing doesn't work.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apply thing?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, because it said, when I click on short red, it says, apply healing from hit dice rolled after taking.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then you need to click on the actual hit dice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Ah, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you actually need to.
[SPEAKER_04]: So.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: Boy plus three constitution.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's still not enough.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: I am back to full life then at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so yeah, you guys spend some time there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you want to do something else as well?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oscar was you were there then, or are you just getting yourself kind of disguised up, taking a rest, getting ready?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so, uh, arriving at Salvador slip Felix and luck, uh, you guys arrive Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not only a place you've never been, but probably a place that's a little out of.
[SPEAKER_02]: your normal circles, I think, as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, whilst you might have...
[SPEAKER_02]: I feel like I just got waterproofed in here a few times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey.
[SPEAKER_02]: To be determined.
[SPEAKER_07]: He's a classy man.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am very classy.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, growing up, I think you would know about these kind of places, bath houses, and etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not something you would have visited, given your rocky childhood and adoption and such things.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you arrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as do you like Emory is not on the door at this time of day.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't need a doorman during the
[SPEAKER_02]: like regular hours of the day so you're able to just walk straight in and as you enter you see that actually Delilah is at the slip kind of in a kind of sorry not Delilah Delia
[SPEAKER_02]: is at the front kind of desk but she's just like hanging around basically doing the greeting job and checking on people etc and you hear a bit of a rumble of like conversation and you know every other time you've been here it's been like quite late at night whereas this is like middle of the afternoon there's plenty of people coming and going there's people in the bathroom it's actually taking baths and stuff and it's relatively lively here for a change but Delia spots you as you walk in Lark and
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, oh, oh, hey, we don't normally see you this early on.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I decided to be nice to Madam Rook today and come earlier than her sleeping time.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I'm going to go see her upstairs.
[SPEAKER_07]: And my friend Felix, Mr. Felix here, he's going to just, I think, take a bath and I'll look at him.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just a bath.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, that would be nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just a bath.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a penny.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she's kind of like just just towards the lockbox there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says, you know, you'll you towels around the corner.
[SPEAKER_02]: Men's baths are that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Feel free to stay as long as you like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't make any trouble.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sure you won't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she directs you off and you can take a short rest, Felix, as you go and take a bath, unless you want to do anything else in the bath.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's relatively like boisterous at this time of day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Boisterous.
[SPEAKER_02]: In terms of there's a lot of in the men's bath, there's just a lot of like, the kind of like older guys that you see like type of people that hang around in bath houses and saunas and stuff like that who don't have anything else to do and like just killing time retirees and like older people and that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's plenty of like kind of a bit of banter going backward and forward between people and they obviously know each other.
[SPEAKER_02]: A lot of them know each other relatively well because they're regulars here.
[SPEAKER_02]: They probably come like every lunchtime and, you know, hang out before they go back to their shift or they or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you're able to head upstairs, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as you head upstairs, you start to walk up the stairs to the third flight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I don't know if you want to go straight there or
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I'll go straight to Madame.
[SPEAKER_07]: I am carrying my stuff with me as well because I have not left them at Billy's or anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you have like your staff with like a bindle, like a whole cloth.
[SPEAKER_02]: bundle full of shit, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm seeing it a little bit over.
[SPEAKER_07]: And it's actually like even when we were at the Claring Bones, I just like drop my stuff at the office when I go like run outside or anything.
[SPEAKER_07]: But anyway, I'm carrying my stuff when we move to places.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, potentially going back there soon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but you can obviously kind of drop it by the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: But as you go to head up the third flight of stairs or the second flight of stairs to the third floor, a girl sort of rushes past you that you see.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's got her head down and she looks a little bit like, I'll make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's her favourite.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, with a 12, like she just looks a little bit maybe like embarrassed or
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, probably embarrassed is the best word.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like she just looks a little bit like she's clearly just been in Madame Rook's office.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so she kind of rushes past you on the stairs with a little bit of a hurry step.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not running, but she's like, wants to get out of there as quick as possible, basically.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you head up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the door is still kind of just closing as you get to the top of the stairs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and Madam Rook actually sees you as the doors closing as you kind of like pass this, this girl and she beckons you in and says, uh, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hi, I'm here earlier today.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hopefully by your request.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Um, uh, yes, I came to discuss maybe, maybe about future plans.
[SPEAKER_01]: Future plans.
[SPEAKER_07]: if we might have them for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I believe I said I might be able to find a job for you potentially, or at least a task for you to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it turns out that one has fallen on our laps, so to speak.
[SPEAKER_02]: One that I could certainly use your help with.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's a pain
[SPEAKER_02]: job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very straightforward.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will pay you two marks for this delivery job, essentially.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm so good at deliveries.
[SPEAKER_02]: That I understand you have some experience in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, you may have seen on the table there, Mary, unfortunately, had to put in a complaint about a gentleman that came last night.
[SPEAKER_07]: I love this job, give it to me.
[SPEAKER_07]: I didn't say that, I said it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what we need you to do is just deliver a letter
[SPEAKER_02]: to this man, but of course you're going to deliver the letter whilst the man is at work and unfortunately his wife will be in the home.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we want you to make sure that she reads this letter that you're delivering.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think you understand the ramifications.
[SPEAKER_02]: wife needs to read yes okay the most finished accent possible um so i yes i'm just in the process of writing a very polite letter to this gentleman and you just simply need to ensure that he receives the letter uh but of course when he happens to not be in the house um and somehow use your
[SPEAKER_02]: wiles to convince the lady of the house that it could be important and she might wish to open up the mail and just check it before he gets home.
[SPEAKER_07]: Does this man work regular work hours if he's coming here from nine to five or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you know that?
[SPEAKER_02]: He comes in the evenings, I believe that he works in one of the forges in the core, so he'll be away most of the day, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would recommend, obviously, that you don't bump into him either before or after.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least, I'm sure you'll be able to come up with something if that happens, but I don't think he will take it very kindly
[SPEAKER_02]: If he finds out what your intention is here, let's put it that way.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_07]: This sounds perfect.
[SPEAKER_07]: I am able to do this job and I will do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: She finishes kind of finishing up writing a letter, fold it up, puts it into a thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: She puts her seal on the envelope as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: And passes it over to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, Yes, he lives just on the edge of the core.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you know Oblong Square?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not too far.
[SPEAKER_02]: Couple of blocks and she gives you some directions to a house that's relatively near Oblong Square in the core.
[SPEAKER_02]: And
[SPEAKER_02]: Tilbury is his name, Amos Tilbury.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it'll be Mr. and Mrs. Tilbury, obviously, the intended recipient, Mrs. Tilbury.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's the man's name?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: What's the wife's name?
[SPEAKER_07]: Mrs. Tilbury.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you asking her?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: She just said Mrs. Tilbury.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think this is all I need and I have the letter and I will deliver it and bring you back to news how I succeeded.
[SPEAKER_02]: I admire your confidence.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll see you soon, I suppose.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: Have a good rest of the evening.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I politely leave.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I think I quickly rush to Nell's room to check if she's there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to knock?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you hear her kind of shuffle around and say, come in.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's me, Nell.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, you're here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: With an S.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm so glad I caught you today.
[SPEAKER_07]: I had to leave last time.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm sorry, I just took my stuff and you were with the customer so I didn't want to, of course, bother you.
[SPEAKER_07]: I got a job from Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have it now in my hands and I'm gonna
[SPEAKER_02]: do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she looks happy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she goes, Oh, that's so good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm glad everything went well with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And when and Madam Rook, like, I thought, yeah, things might have been, I don't know, like, problematic.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's been in a kind of like on and off mood.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then no walks through the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: One second, I've got to do something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, well, that's all that's awesome.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, it's really cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to be like staying here or?
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't think I have that permission yet so I'll just figure out my sleeping situation for a few days elsewhere.
[SPEAKER_07]: Hopefully in the future if I do a good job she might give me a room or maybe I can stay in the spare rooms if there are like three rooms in the evenings.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think we're pretty tight on rooms, so I think that might be tough.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, I mean, she's great if you get on a good side.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, she knows a lot of people and she knows a lot of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, she can maybe help you out with all that stuff you're telling me about.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, yeah, just, well, I haven't told you names and stuff.
[SPEAKER_07]: So just keep quiet on the things that I told you, because they're escalating pretty quickly.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I'm gonna close the door behind me and just go whisper things, these things to her.
[SPEAKER_07]: I actually, you said you never get to do anything exciting.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I actually have a mission for you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, gods.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my gods.
[SPEAKER_02]: A mission.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I want you to have some names in mind.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if you hear these names in the bathhouse whenever in any situation, just try to listen in without, of course, being nosy.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just like if you're doing anything regular, you know, just be nonchalant about it.
[SPEAKER_07]: And if you hear some of these names, just keep your ears open and try to listen in, OK?
[SPEAKER_07]: These names are, and I say Evan's name and I say the other two that we got from the porters guild.
[SPEAKER_07]: So Evan Langford you have.
[SPEAKER_07]: And Sasha Langford I think as well, if anything's talked about Sasha.
[SPEAKER_07]: And then Bertrude and the... Yeah, you only have the first names for Gertrude and Alastair.
[SPEAKER_07]: character, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I described how they look because that's like probably more important than they're probably not going to say their name.
[SPEAKER_07]: So if you see these people, if they come here, or if you hear these names that they are talked about here, just try to listen in.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just be very careful that you don't get caught of listening in.
[SPEAKER_07]: And just come up with a good excuse if you do.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, just don't get yourself in trouble.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, no problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean,
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm here all the time.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll listen out.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'll be perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can be nonchalant.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've never been chalant in my life.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: Thank you, Nell, because I think this is a good place to maybe hear some rumours.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, we hear all kinds of stuff, but most of the time it doesn't mean anything because, you know, we just get on with our stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But that's how Madame Rook gets all of her information and stuff, you know, it's like,
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like we tell her and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: So like if I hear about these people, do you think like I should tell Madame Rook as well?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or you want me to just like keep it secret?
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, don't tell Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, no, keep this secret that I've...
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, one of the other girls might tell Madame Rook.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, I won't tell her that you told me to tell her, but if I hear some stuff to tell her, should I tell her or should I just tell you the stuff or should I tell both of you the stuff?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just tell me first.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just tell me first, because like she doesn't know anything.
[SPEAKER_07]: And she doesn't know that you're listening.
[SPEAKER_07]: You're just listening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, no, she knows that we're listening.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's kind of the point.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where do you think she gets all like her information and stuff from, you know?
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, okay, never mind.
[SPEAKER_07]: Maybe you can tell her, but just, okay, you tell her about that, also tell me.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just tell her and tell me.
[SPEAKER_07]: But don't tell her that you are telling me as well, okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't tell her that you told me not to tell her.
[SPEAKER_07]: Don't tell her that I told you to listen in and that you are telling me.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, got it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't tell her that I'm telling you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And don't tell her that you told me to listen in, but still tell her and you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Tell her about the things you hear.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: But not about you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Like you're supposed to.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's your job.
[SPEAKER_07]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_07]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_07]: Great.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: This is a big thing now.
[SPEAKER_07]: Just don't get caught.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because it might be dangerous.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: Good.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have to go do this job now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you going to beat someone up?
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know, maybe.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm actually just trying to...
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know if I can tell you about this job.
[SPEAKER_07]: You know what?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I'm going to beat someone up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, cool.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, just kidding.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, just... Yeah, let's... You kind of look like you were beating someone up earlier.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, I guess Lakk doesn't really, because Lakk wasn't really involved in the fight at all.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's what I went through.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, true, true.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just like rained on, but nothing.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, just have a good work day and let's see around.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I'll go.
[SPEAKER_07]: See you, Lakk.
[SPEAKER_07]: See you.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I'll just go at the lobby, wait if I see Felix or just wait him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You also want to take a short rest here?
[SPEAKER_07]: Um, I mean, I guess.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Felix is going to take a short rest here, then you'll have to wait around for him and you might as well take a short rest as well.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, I'm taking the short rest in the lobby.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're just killing some time here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can chat to Delia and everything as you're here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I guess it's just down to Colder.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you had anything you were going to do after Billy's.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you guys will be up again.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think I don't want Billy to be completely alone on his own.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think I would suggest that we start to go to the drop location and then Billy can stay a little bit further away and then I go and see if I see the letter.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you head out towards the nearest Bellows entrance that you know of, you know the Bellows relatively well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, I can't remember how often you go to the Bellows, if you go at all, is it like...
[SPEAKER_05]: I kind of vowed to never go back again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, right, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Korgi is leading you to the Bellows at the moment.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think in this situation, I usually would say, well, no, I'm scared, but maybe
[SPEAKER_05]: something about William has changed a bit that he can overcome that fear quite easily.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, Calder starts to take you down into the bellows and start to he clearly knows his way around as he takes you kind of around some particular bends and stuff and you end up in an area of the bellows that is definitely less populated than some of the other areas where there is one or two people walking past every now and again but it's not like the residential built up areas where there's like people relatively regularly and it gets a little
[SPEAKER_02]: you know, creepier, I guess, in a little... As you're walking down the tunnel, you can both make perception checks.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do we have any... Did we take those one pieces or something from the office?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think we took like a little bit of these guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: those are working.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can be, you can be wearing some office, but you guys, you guys were Billy's first, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, but we, we could have taken them from, if you wanted to wear them as like a, a mid-shift disguise kind of thing, or at least to change your clothing, to look a bit more working class kind of like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, they're kind of like Billy's clothes anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not, not that different for them really.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, both of you made perception checks for me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is there, I don't have any exhaustion or anything, I'm just completely fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, I think you're fine, but now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do, either of you know low talk?
[SPEAKER_02]: I recognize it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, then you recognize some low talk, but you do not speak it, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And I don't think... Where did I see those again?
[SPEAKER_02]: In your languages, we added them in the one on one.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just on your character sheet in the languages box.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we'll kind of get close to Caller and almost whisper to him, I guess.
[SPEAKER_05]: Probably I would ask him if he recognizes this.
[SPEAKER_05]: like rhythmic tapping that or whatever we're hearing or seeing it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's like a rhythmic kind of tapping and an occasional like high pitch whistle that would almost maybe sound even like a steam whistle or something if you didn't know that it was somebody doing it, which you obviously know what it is used for like communicating down here.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do I know?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, not at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you hearing something?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think as Billy points it out with your 17, it's like, oh, that's not just normal sounds that happen down here.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not just pipes banging together and steam whistles.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy is basically pointing out like, oh, you hear that?
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear that?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's actually somebody communicating, not just the random noises of the bellows.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you didn't realize that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've probably heard it before, but you didn't realize it was a specific communication method because it's not something you've ever used before.
[SPEAKER_00]: So do you understand it?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I don't, but just, you know, be aware that people are communicating and it might be, you know, to alarm our presence or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is very, very good to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very good to know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's keep our eyes open.
[SPEAKER_00]: More than we do them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, as you say that you do, you do start to walk down and see two guys who are leaning against the side very nonchalantly leaning against the side of the tunnel, but then who pushed themselves off as you approach and sort of walk forwards to meet you in the middle of the tunnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: One guy is much bigger than the other guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: holding a large sort of cudgel.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other guy is a sort of smaller darken.
[SPEAKER_02]: The other one is older, maybe in his late 30s, something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's a big guy as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think before going over there, I think I would say Billy to wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I recognize them further away, I would say Billy to stay back.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want them to meet Billy or Billy to meet them.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I would also
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe take the, probably have my pouch or backpack with me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would probably take some sort of mask as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: How it was called.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you go to put a mask on and basically Calder stops you, Billy tells you to wait there and then goes to put a mask on you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would, I would.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think, like, Billy doesn't know that Calder is familiar to this area, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: He thinks he's like an upstanding college guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Other than him telling you guys a little bit about dangerous people that he knows and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, outside of that, he's, yeah, you don't know anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Billy would be like, well, listen, Calder, this is not your kind of area either.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm not going to let you go alone.
[SPEAKER_05]: We're going to stay with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, trust me, trust me.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll explain after this, yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: As I see him put his mask on, I think I would kind of try to cover my face as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think if you're wearing like the overalls with kind of like something, you can probably like pull up a little kind of like sort of bandana-y type of thing a little bit.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you're not listening to him and you're following him as he walks forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're about 20 feet away from you standing waiting for you guys to approach.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you just go with him as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you both come up about five feet away from them, the darkened goat kind of looks at you both and goes, hello, boys.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you two doing down here all the way out here?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't have, you know, the pictures.
[SPEAKER_00]: I thought those were the pen and... No, no, this is not the people you chose.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are just random guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: They just happen to be one big guy and one small guy, much like... Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, now it makes more sense as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, still doing all the masking things, I guess.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: He woke up and yeah, he says that to you too.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Bidium steps forward.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he will be...
[SPEAKER_05]: I think his expression is a bit more colder than Calder is used to.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he just straight up steps in front of him while he's kind of hesitating to say anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: And Bidium says,
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, what is it to you?
[SPEAKER_05]: Why do you want to know?
[SPEAKER_05]: And I would attempt to make an intimidation with Tides of Chaos to get advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a little crackle of sort of magical aura around Billy as he says this as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, it's not great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good job you had advantage, to be honest.
[SPEAKER_02]: He kind of sneers a little bit, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you say this, and he says, whoa.
[SPEAKER_02]: his voice is not that deep but he says well we operate let's say the informal toll system in the bellows you just have to pay up and we let you go through you know you look like you guys have been down here before you probably know how it works yeah and I called her a culture box next to next to
[SPEAKER_00]: William puts my hand on his shoulder and then, yeah, this is my new associate and I'm sure that you know the names, Mr. C, Mr. K, so we just keep going and then I start to keep walking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make an intimidation check with advantage folder.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ooh, chic!
[SPEAKER_04]: Mr. C, who's Mr. C?
[SPEAKER_05]: Who is doing inside tech from far away?
[SPEAKER_02]: Log just sits up like, I feel like I need to inside someone.
[SPEAKER_07]: Calder said Mr. K and Mr. C. Did you hear that?
[SPEAKER_06]: No idea what you're talking about.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys go to confidently walk between these two guys and the big guy just kind of shoulder checks you and he goes, I don't know who these mister, whoever, ABCD, what the fuck you are paying up.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's, it's two pennies each.
[SPEAKER_01]: Straightforward.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think in that point then Calder stops and I look in the eyes of that guy and I toss silver in that case and say that you better... No, not a ducat, a mark then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, yeah, sorry, Mark, not silver.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, Mark.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then I say that, uh, well, the next time it's better for you to remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'd just leave it like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just try to be cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make one, just make one more straight intimidation check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, as, but you throw them the money that they're asking for.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, um, regardless, it's kind of, uh, just to see how it, how it works.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I help it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you could also make an intimidation check, just a straight roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't.
[SPEAKER_07]: Crimson just wants to see one.
[SPEAKER_02]: One good intimidation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: You throw them the money and you go like, yeah, better.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, you know, Williams like sneers at them like, yeah, but they just do not seem impressed at all.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I never created an intimidating character because if you just roll low, it's just.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you can roll intimidation with strength, which wouldn't help either of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But
[SPEAKER_02]: If you were actually a big strong intimidating guy, you could roll it with a strength bonus instead of charisma and actually have a good chance.
[SPEAKER_02]: But in this case, your charisma is not bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just roll like shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, they just kind of stare and he goes, yeah, whatever you say, mate.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then as you walk off, he goes, this idiot paid double.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think he realizes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go, let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: And they quickly rush off as they take the mark and think that you've just done some bad maths on how much two pennies twice.
[SPEAKER_02]: 2 plus 2 is 4 minus 4 minus 3.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, but you get past them anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you head over to the little steam vent where inside you are looking for the drop that you came down here for.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think because you're coming out of the blue, and if you needed to meet Penn and Dunmore, you would need to leave a message and say, hey, meet me at this time.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah but i think i think we are great too i think we agree to information here yes yeah that's what you're coming for right yeah i just i wasn't sure if you were thinking that you could come down and meet them here because you would need to tell them a time to meet or whatever they're not just waiting around all the time but you come down and find a letter it is uh sealed with uh that seal that i totally remember what it is um
[SPEAKER_07]: Where are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: I will find it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a moth pressed into grey wax.
[SPEAKER_02]: You find a sealed scroll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sealed with... Yeah, so Billy, I think you spot this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or unless you're trying to hide it from him, Kolde, it's up to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I probably don't try to hide it, but I'm probably not also going, you know, showing it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So then it's up to you, Billy, if you...
[SPEAKER_02]: politely stay back as Calder does his business or you are just kind of like hanging around near him so you'll be able to see what he's doing.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I know that we're coming here with a reason that Calder has something planned here and so I know it's kind of dodgy but I think I would let him just do his thing.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm not really looking to
[SPEAKER_05]: to sneak in on what he's trying to do.
[SPEAKER_05]: And if he tries to like read it on his own, I would let him.
[SPEAKER_07]: What's the location or did you say it out loud?
[SPEAKER_07]: Sorry, I missed it.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's just in the bellows.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just a one of these steam terminals, a particular steam terminal that it has like a little, so it's one of these like steam outlet kind of chimney things that's built into the walls of the bellows that are often used as like landmarks when you're down here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't say the number, but...
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh yeah, on the one-on-one, you probably sell the number.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think it would be the same one.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think it's the same one.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not that one that you have previously met people at, because you're not going to use the same one for everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think in this case, it's just a random one that was pre-arranged.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not the common one that you would go to.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just like a pre-arranged drop place, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you pull out the scroll.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you open it here to read it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, what are you doing now with it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you have it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I probably would take it and put it on my pocket and then go back to William.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, let's continue.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's go to the...
[SPEAKER_02]: I think Billy also make a perception check as all this happens.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're rolling so well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see much of interest.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're kind of like hanging back a little bit as Calder just produces a scroll here and says, okay, let's go back.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't open it here to read it yet, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, no, I probably want to wait that I'm we are back on the out of these tunnels, basement and back in the open world, so to say, and then I would read it on the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So as you start to head back, you read the scroll and it has information from both Penn and Dunmore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Penn, who was watching the Volan building in the outlines, his report basically is like, kind of not interesting, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's just saying that basically the people you would expect to come and go from the Volan house, like the servants, and then occasionally the Volans when they go, you know, and Valoran is seen leaving to go to the,
[SPEAKER_02]: engineering spire and back every day but it's only been like two days right since you gave him this message so no one of like major interest has has turned up there or you know nothing to report basically Dunmore's report specifically was about whether there was people being held at the Porter's Guild spire you didn't give him the specific names of
[SPEAKER_02]: who you were interested in.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he reports kind of having spoken to some people, et cetera, that there are people held in the Porter's Guild spire, kind of everyone knows that.
[SPEAKER_02]: People did report that, or somebody mentions that somebody matching, someone that you matched to Shrapnel's description from Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: So basically somebody who looked like Shrapnel was taken in around the time that you expected.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that rumor comes out as to be expected, you think Shrapnel is basically in the spire.
[SPEAKER_02]: Other people have been taken in and out and because Dunmore doesn't know exactly who you're after, none of them sort of line up particularly with anything else interesting to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is more or less already what we...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would tell Billy about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to hide or anything the information about that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm like saying to Billy that there was nothing too much information.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is somewhat confirmation that Europass have been seen.
[SPEAKER_00]: taken by the guild but we already.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which guild?
[SPEAKER_02]: Engineering?
[SPEAKER_02]: Was it engineering?
[SPEAKER_02]: Porter's guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: You send to the Porter's guild Spire to look for them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is where Gertrude and Alistair are from and Evan is from the Porter's guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But we already got essentially this information.
[SPEAKER_02]: You didn't know necessarily where he was being held, just that the Poison Skill took him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guessed it was probably the Spire, but now you have it confirmed basically that he was seen being taken into the Spire.
[SPEAKER_02]: so you guys head to the cobbler's pot where you guys all meet up in the early afternoon this is was once an old cobble cobbler's shop a person that makes shoes that has been converted into a tavern that still has many of the tools and shoe horns on the wall and all the rest of it and is a busy place where you
[SPEAKER_02]: not so busy in the middle of the afternoon that you guys can't find a table in a corner to talk, but there's plenty of people coming and going so it's not, you don't look suspicious or weird in a group on a table any more than you would in any other tavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so you guys gather up.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Eska would say, hey, it's me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh yeah, and Eska's in disguise.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think there's some shocked looks when you join.
[SPEAKER_03]: So yeah, after we sat down, the first thing Eska is going to ask is so, Lark, how did it go?
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, well, I have a new job.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's in my backpack and I have to do it.
[SPEAKER_07]: quickly probably, but yeah, it went well as far as I know.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: And Felix got a bath.
[SPEAKER_03]: Very important information.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you, Lark.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you disclose any information about this job that you have?
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, it's actually a delivery job.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have to bring a letter of complaint.
[SPEAKER_03]: A letter of complaint.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, that's really easy.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I'm going to do it at some point today, I think.
[SPEAKER_07]: Or maybe tomorrow because today, what time is it now?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's in the evening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's like three, four PM.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys only took a short rest and then got maybe four, five.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I have to do it during work hours, I'm pretty sure.
[SPEAKER_07]: So tomorrow morning, I'll do it.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess that... Yeah, I guess you're just gonna have to do it and I assume that you haven't given Madame Rook any extra information and she hasn't given you any extra information.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, I haven't and I will not...
[SPEAKER_07]: I promise I won't.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, sorry.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just had to ask.
[SPEAKER_03]: My apologies.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's okay, sorry.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: No problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Calder and William, how...
[SPEAKER_01]: Did things go on your end?
[SPEAKER_04]: Uneventful?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, we got some cleaning, some rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, and you do look better.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thanks.
[SPEAKER_05]: You too.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're still hot.
[SPEAKER_03]: William, how are you feeling?
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you still the same?
[SPEAKER_03]: You're OK?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm fine, I think.
[SPEAKER_05]: Still quite tired, but...
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess, good enough.
[SPEAKER_07]: You know, there's this new kind of glow to you, Billy.
[SPEAKER_04]: On your chest, maybe.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess you and Felix have that in common now.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe it helps you getting in control of your magic.
[SPEAKER_05]: Something else might help me.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I wave over to a waitress or anyone that's serving.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll have a beer, please.
[SPEAKER_05]: First alcoholic drink in his life.
[SPEAKER_05]: Really?
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: At least surprisingly confident to call over the witches over.
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably different than you've seen him before, maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you a bit young to drink beer?
[SPEAKER_04]: No.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're all adults.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think there's a drinking age.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think even if there wasn't, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the drinking age would be like 15, 16 in this time period plus everything, but I think Larka is insinuating that you are 15 or under or young.
[SPEAKER_03]: She's not wrong, but I still order a beer.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess Eska, just for the sake of it, also orders one.
[SPEAKER_03]: I also want one.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, a round for the table, is it?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, no, no, not for me, thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: Also for her.
[SPEAKER_07]: A round for the table, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she walks off to go and fetch some drinks for you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark, aren't you a bit young to drink?
[SPEAKER_07]: No.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm turning 19 in 95 days.
Oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, well, guess it's an early celebration then.
[SPEAKER_03]: Anyways.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so we are... Yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's discuss what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think Kaldor would have reacted to the lorax age like, ah, so we are very similar age.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm 19 myself.
[SPEAKER_00]: So how young or old is Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: And again, William would turn to Calder and it's like, wait, I thought you were like a couple of years older than me.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he says, I'm also 19.
[SPEAKER_07]: You're joking, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: No.
[SPEAKER_07]: Dark's face crumbles like, you're serious?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: Most awkward.
[SPEAKER_05]: What are we talking about again?
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark, you said you had some ideas, right?
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, I already presented one of them and you didn't want to do it.
[SPEAKER_07]: And the other one was talking to Mira about Evan or asking because she might know something about the guildies and also maybe Brassline has some deliveries related to them.
[SPEAKER_07]: which I don't know how much information she would give, but I would try to do my best to get them.
[SPEAKER_07]: That's a couple ideas I have.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, and then we have the other leads that, you know, Billy's previous colleagues took the interior of the safe as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever that might have been could be informative.
[SPEAKER_00]: What else do we have then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Then we have ISCAS family connection to this whole thingy.
[SPEAKER_00]: If we can somehow, I don't know, get information from that side.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then of course, Professor Benjamin Parkling as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I in principle could go try to sneak to his office room and the colleague to see if there is any notation about the project or something and yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: And we should find out more about these cores in Billy's and Felix's chests.
[SPEAKER_07]: And what happened to Felix, who's behind it?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I'm really curious who's targeting you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_05]: Me too.
[SPEAKER_05]: It seems someone really is looking out to get you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: And they're not doing it in a friendly way.
[SPEAKER_06]: I would tell you don't normally meet such people who don't have a heart actually, but have something else instead.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you think it's related to the people that you were working for and they, I mean, they removed you from your position, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: They wanted you gone.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you think it's the same people?
[SPEAKER_06]: Might be related, but I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_05]: You did say that your colleague that you met up with, she was targeted as well, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, she was indeed, but I also have no idea who was behind that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, it seems to me that maybe there's a pattern.
[SPEAKER_05]: that maybe there are more of your colleagues that are no longer working for the guild and maybe do you know of anyone else that was maybe
[SPEAKER_06]: Fired or attacked or anything?
[SPEAKER_06]: Not that I know of.
[SPEAKER_06]: I only worked close with Theodore and then my direct boss from the secretary was also fired and that's the only one I worked with.
[SPEAKER_01]: I was also still a bit hiding because of what happened.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, either way, it seems that there are now three assassination attempts on you and your colleagues.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I would definitely call that a pattern if nothing else.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who would you say is the most likely to benefit from
[SPEAKER_05]: you and your colleagues no longer being in that position.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, it seems that the construct was targeting Felix and the last time from at least from what Felix has told us when he got the ledger, his colleague was being targeted for that as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: The people behind that also knew that Felix had the ledger, seeing as they didn't kill the secretary, and so she managed to give it to Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, so this should be connected to why they probably want Felix dead now, because they know that he took the ledger away.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, but this kind of creature I've seen before, I killed a similar one while I was running away from the place I was captured.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it is something from that place.
[SPEAKER_05]: So do you think we can find more information about this place?
[SPEAKER_06]: If we can find this place, we can get probably more information about the essence that it's now running in us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Was that in Parvo or somewhere else?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, it was in Parvo, but that building is abandoned now.
[SPEAKER_06]: So they moved places.
[SPEAKER_04]: Should we go there and see if there's anything remaining?
[SPEAKER_04]: Would give it a try.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe we didn't see anything last time we were there, but maybe we can find a clue.
[SPEAKER_00]: And did you see many of those creatures?
[SPEAKER_06]: I killed one and then another one appeared, but then I escaped.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I see.
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't want to fight another one.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, understandable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you know if they... Well, it sounds like there start to be multiple of these.
[SPEAKER_00]: So do you know if they have any weaknesses or anything that we can use to against?
[SPEAKER_06]: Not that I know of.
[SPEAKER_06]: Only used fire on it and it was just normal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I mean, you...
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry, this is a bit off the game, but you knew that they're weak to thunder, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Because you used thunder damage and you saw that it did more damage to the construct, didn't you?
[SPEAKER_00]: To the howl construct?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, for those, but these big machine... Oh, sorry, the big machine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I thought they were talking about the howls.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know how these big machine thingies are called.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, none of you know what they are, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you're calling them constructs kind of because they have essence core power and some of them are metal, but they're not anything really like constructs in that sense.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're closer to humanoid creatures than they are to animals, which essentially constructs are like animals, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So this is like a whole new genre of thing that you've never encountered before, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So whether they're related to those howls that you
[SPEAKER_02]: that you fought in the bellows or not, you don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: But they're certainly, the only thing you've got connecting them is that Felix has already seen two similar creatures.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I will say, Felix, you know, the ones you saw were smaller and less dangerous than this one appeared to be.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like they weren't eight foot hulking brutes.
[SPEAKER_02]: The one you killed was like a regular human sized kind of thing that was dangerous.
[SPEAKER_06]: They only used two attacks on it and then died also.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, it was dangerous, but it definitely wasn't, it wasn't the same threat level as this thing was.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's obviously different types and potentially, you know, perhaps it's evolved in the time since you, you know, fought one as well, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Perhaps the methodology has evolved or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been a year, so it's hard to say how connected these things are to other things that you guys have seen.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we give them some nickname that it's easier to speak about those creatures?
[SPEAKER_00]: Chompy or walking dead or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think, Coli, you would know the concept of golems.
[SPEAKER_02]: as a constructed like elemental type of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: So these would be closer to something that's like a mindless construct that like wizards might make, but they would be very like high level magic normally to create something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can kind of make these kind of like golems and they remind you more of something like that than
[SPEAKER_02]: a sentient creature or an animal or something, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Something constructed and created for a single purpose or with a very limited like sentience or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, so should we call them?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: muted, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: Totally has a bot in her face.
[SPEAKER_06]: A giant catbot in her face.
[SPEAKER_07]: Great screenshot.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's good.
[SPEAKER_07]: Sorry, I was listening.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I guess...
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, I can...
[SPEAKER_02]: I can add to Billy's question earlier about who would benefit from potentially like Theo's friends at the.
[SPEAKER_02]: the guild being removed, et cetera, you guys can make, you can make politics checks for this kind of thing to see if you know about the internals of, you know, and how this might affect things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my God.
[SPEAKER_07]: And Crimson, Lark probably didn't see anyone looking at us when we were talking.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the 21, like this is the kind of place where people don't look at each other very much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like they keep to themselves and it's not, you know, it doesn't seem like anybody is listening in on you with a 21.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think, Billy, you think about that question and just think like.
[SPEAKER_02]: The most logical thing, or the only connection that you guys have so far to this particular question, is the fact that Theo and the people connected to Theo have been removed, quote-unquote.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Theo was physically, was assassinated, and then it seemed like people connected to Theo at the Guild, so Felix and Harriet, were both then dismissed straight away without, seemingly without cause and without, so it seems like
[SPEAKER_02]: That's connected in the way that, like, whoever wanted to get rid of Theo also wanted to make sure no Theo allies were left in the guild, right, by getting rid of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if Felix wasn't necessarily involved in anything Theo was doing or whatever, it seemed like a bit of a housekeeping for the assassination to make sure that they could remove people from the guild as well that might have knowledge of what Theo was doing, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Whether that's related to why he was assassinated or not, you don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: But, you know, it just seemed like the connection is people that knew Theo, right, or worked closely with Theo.
[SPEAKER_07]: Can I say something that's bothering me?
[SPEAKER_07]: I am worried that
[SPEAKER_07]: The dangers we face constantly are just starting to grow and we know that we are in danger and some of us, our faces are now, most of our faces are now known in some ways to our so-called enemies but we haven't gathered any more allies than what our small little group is and we are working in the shadows and hiding and avoiding
[SPEAKER_07]: I think it would be beneficial if we got powerful allies and I'm sure there are people who liked Mr. Theodore and would help us if they just knew.
[SPEAKER_07]: But we aren't known to anyone like that and we haven't tried to find allies like that.
[SPEAKER_07]: And we should try to find powerful people to help us in this case.
[SPEAKER_00]: I sort of agree, but it's also very dangerous to give out information to essentially random people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we cannot really know if they're on the enemy side, so to say.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then if we gave any of this information freely, then it's even more bad for us.
[SPEAKER_07]: Not really.
[SPEAKER_04]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was just going to say, Aski, you can make a politics check again, this time on that sort of topic of allies and enemies and such things.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because I was just going to ask from Eska, like Mr. Eska, like, did you know anyone who really was friends with Theo or liked Theo?
[SPEAKER_07]: that would have a powerful position or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_07]: Or Mr. Felix, maybe you as well, since you were close to him for a year.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can also make a politics check, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think, Aske, Theo was kind of low down in the guild when you were there, to the point where you didn't really pay attention.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's like below
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not worth your time to be invested in the lower levels.
[SPEAKER_02]: He wasn't necessarily at the level he was when he was assassinated when you were at the Guild as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he would have been like a lower level clerk.
[SPEAKER_02]: You wouldn't have necessarily followed his groups of friends or his influence or whatever like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think Felix as well, you did get the impression that
[SPEAKER_02]: Steele was in the Guild because he was pretty good at it and it paid money and it allowed him to have some influence but I don't think he enjoyed the politics side of being in the Guild and he wasn't trying to work his way up and he wasn't schmoozing other people in the Guild and trying to get promotions all the time and stuff, the kind of things that you would need to do to work your way up.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was more focused on his own stuff and he just kind of
[SPEAKER_02]: It was his job at the guild was as much as he was interested in, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just doing his job and getting, you know, and then doing his side stuff in terms of his talks and political aspirations and other stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Unfortunately, I do not know anyone.
[SPEAKER_03]: When I was in the guild, Theo was still working his way up and he seems to be more of the hardworking type, not the making connections type.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I unfortunately do not have any information regarding that matter.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think, Laak, you probably think that allies, he's more likely to have allies in the lower classes of Parvo than he is to have allies in the higher echelons, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because he's more likely to have made friends with his political stuff.
[SPEAKER_07]: But I still worded that question correctly, because she is thinking if there would be any powerful people who would have liked him, maybe.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: But not that Asuka knows, at least, if there was.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: OK. Well, that's harder for us, then.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think one thing, as well, Asuka, that I'll just give you for free is that I think you also, seeing that there are various different guilds and potential people involved in things that are connected to you guys,
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you think about the idea that people have or various factions have different motivations and they're not all necessarily on the same side, so to speak, versus you guys, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: They might also be versus each other and there might be, you know, just because they're all against you,
[SPEAKER_02]: doesn't mean they're all on the same side as well right and you know obviously from the guilds all the guilds aspire to one up each other and try and become the the more powerful and make more money and blah blah blah so likely people like the porters guild and the guild of engineers are not working together on on stuff uh or it's unlikely that that there's like maybe there's small alliances between individuals but as a as general factions there's probably more multiple things going on that you guys happen to have got
[SPEAKER_02]: mixed up into the middle of, but it doesn't mean that there's like one overarching plot that everybody is, is in on, you know?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I guess I can, yeah, I can try to identify the, the, the compass that we got for now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, but that would require a long rest, so that would be later.
[SPEAKER_03]: For now, yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: What is our plan for tonight?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think we're supposed to meet and discuss what we're going to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but I mean, I feel like we have so many different options that we should just pick one of them, like all those that I previously mentioned, but then also should we try to look for the two kidnapped guys as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: We know that Evans is holding them and we got confirmation that Billy's boss is captured and held.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, and well, if we want to find more info on Evan, I could ask Mira before we go and do anything physical.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I think we already discussed that you would go to Evan, Mira.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, and like Calder and Billy or in any case, Billy would like to look into the, the, his colleagues, you know, who stole stuff from the safe.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that part we got to, and we don't know if we haven't discussed if anyone's going to join Billy.
[SPEAKER_03]: But at least that's the two things that we have right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Um, and yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You actually have the homes asker of both Alfie and Hollis from the employee records that you found in the office.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can actually pinpoint both of their homes.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't live in the same place, so you could pick one to go to, whatever.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that is a whole thread that potentially leads you to something that was taken from Shrutnel as a line of inquiry.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Billion would definitely be down to kick down some doors for us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Starting with Horace.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I think looking at the records.
[SPEAKER_02]: Looking at the records, let me look it up actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the place that Hollis has down as his address is a place called the Firebox.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a boxing gym that he maybe lives at or you don't know, but he's put that down as his address, which is a place in the stacks of boxing gym called the Firebox.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whereas Alfie lives just midway up the stacks in a neighborhood that is not particularly
[SPEAKER_02]: remarkable, but you have his address in the midway up the stack somewhere that he lives.
[SPEAKER_02]: So both of those, both of those locations are easily pinpointable for you guys to get to.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, what Eska would suggest is that he would give the two addresses and he would say, well, William, is there a place that you would like to start between the two?
[SPEAKER_03]: It seems like one of them has an address and one of them is a boxing gym or whatever the place is.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think the gym is probably a good place to start.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: To get some information.
[SPEAKER_04]: Or to just confront them with their behavior.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, in that case, I could check the other house.
[SPEAKER_00]: Should we go in pairs?
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's split up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we can all go together.
[SPEAKER_00]: That is true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Big gang, more intimidating.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK. Well, that works.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, certainly the firebox is in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: The place that Lark needs to go is also in the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: All these places are relatively near to Salador's slip on the east side of the stack.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the place Lark needs to go is relatively close by.
[SPEAKER_02]: The firebox is near and Alfie's house are all relatively near.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're all relatively near Billy's house as well.
[SPEAKER_07]: If you need to go there.
[SPEAKER_02]: The address you have to go and deliver to a house on the edge of the core is like all of these places are in the same rough kind of neighbourhood, this sort of eastern side of the stacks, although it's not called east in this scenario.
[SPEAKER_02]: So all those things can be visited kind of one by one together if you guys want to go together or if you want to split up you'll all be relatively near each other but you don't have much communication to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: The question is whether you want to do any of that tonight or are you finding a place to sleep and doing it in the morning?
[SPEAKER_02]: And what's the order of operations basically for you guys right now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because then also Asuka will potentially get some information on the watch when he sleeps to be able to identify it.
[SPEAKER_06]: We also have to get back to work tomorrow morning, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Elix also has to go to work tomorrow morning, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I guess Calder has to go to the college tomorrow as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not necessary.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm on my free, you know, free studies basically that, you know, the boss or Professor Benium is not over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't necessarily need to be all the time around.
[SPEAKER_02]: No supervisor.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's like 4 or 5 p.m. today.
[SPEAKER_02]: The question is really
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you guys going to find a place to sleep tonight, do a long rest, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go in the morning, but Felix will have to go to work at least for the first half of the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or you want to get some of the stuff done tonight before you find a place to long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_07]: I could talk to Mira today before finding a place to sleep.
[SPEAKER_07]: I think that would help further if I could just talk to her.
[SPEAKER_07]: Also, I have a fundamental problem.
[SPEAKER_07]: I am carrying my stuff all the time.
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't have a place to put them.
[SPEAKER_07]: I have this sack of stuff.
[SPEAKER_07]: So I need to figure out where I can keep this so I don't have to drag it with me.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because I don't have a place to sleep like permanently.
[SPEAKER_04]: Billy's place?
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, if you're okay with leaving them there.
[SPEAKER_05]: look towards Billy you can see him kind of powering through his beer like you can tell he doesn't like it but he's like determined to drink it and then waving to the waitress another round well Lux already got a spare beer that she's not drinking I'm just giving it to Felix slowly like pushing it to Felix
[SPEAKER_07]: You're the biggest, so maybe you can hold it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to hold it more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eska is just like...
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I don't think... Eska is thinking to himself like, okay, this might not be great for Lark to stay with Billy if he's in this state.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_07]: No, that's actually a good idea.
[SPEAKER_07]: Maybe someone needs to bring Billy home and explain to his mother why that he has drank.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've not need to go home.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not that think you should drunk.
[SPEAKER_05]: I am.
[SPEAKER_05]: I've.
[SPEAKER_05]: only had one, so that it's fine with the one, what?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let's, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: What?
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll bring him home.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then I look over to the lock and I say to the lock, I could pay for your accommodations for one night.
[SPEAKER_07]: Oh, that's too nice.
[SPEAKER_07]: I can't take that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, well, just take it anyways, and I put down whatever is necessary to stay for a night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it depends where you're staying.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think this place probably doesn't have rooms, but...
[SPEAKER_07]: Anywhere like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, in a nearby tavern, you can definitely stay if you're going to pay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also, who paid for the round?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's five pennies, five beers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Penny a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: If it's paid upfront, William would have paid it.
[SPEAKER_05]: If it's not paid upfront from Penny.
[SPEAKER_02]: He has no idea.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think she probably took the payment when she first delivered the first five.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's one mark and one penny for the round.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I've got some prices, let me just look for what it's like.
[SPEAKER_03]: We don't use Electrum, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so it's one gold is four silvers, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: That was the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's the base of four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'll tell you how much, I'm just looking how much it will cost you to get a night's accommodation here, because I did make a thing for this to make it more, to make it easier for me to work out.
[SPEAKER_07]: It doesn't solve my problem of having my stuff somewhere though, but... Yeah, it helps your problem for one night.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, one Marker Knight for a decent tavern basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you're paying that and for yourself Asuka, then you guys staying in the same tavern?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like get a room like in the same tavern or?
[SPEAKER_07]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so that it doesn't matter where you are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I'll pay at the end of the night then because yeah, and you can come with me and then we can go to the tavern.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so to wrap this up for this episode, Lark is heading to speak to Mira and then are you going with her, Asuka?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then before you go to a tavern?
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're picking a tavern beforehand to meet at later?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark, do you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which one is fine?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: No, picking a tavern beforehand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you guys pick a tavern, Aska's gonna go rent two rooms there, Lark's gonna go to speak to Mira and then meet him there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kolder is going back to his dorm, presumably, to sleep, yeah?
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, we just talked that we shouldn't split, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: I know, well, you guys keep splitting.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's up to you guys, but I'm just, I'm asking, not saying, but...
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not splitting up, I'm bringing Billy home.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but then where are you going to stay after that?
[SPEAKER_02]: At Billy's?
[SPEAKER_02]: With Billy's mom.
[SPEAKER_02]: He can't stop you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, his dad's not home.
[SPEAKER_03]: In which case, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, again, and Cody, if you want to pay, you can go and stay at the same tavern as Asker and Lark, or I don't know if you want to go with Felix and Billy and all stay at Billy's house, if Billy's OK with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's up to you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Billy's not OK right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think Kalder would ask, do you guys think it would be, because I mean, if I go back to my dorm, I could also try to sneak in to the work office this evening or maybe or night or maybe at least take a quick look like how it looks like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it even possible to do, et cetera, et cetera?
[SPEAKER_07]: Otherwise, the dorm is safe for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, I assume so, but I'm starting to be a little bit worried how all these things are tangled up, because I mean, if Professor Benjamin is also included this, then I don't know who else from the from the colleague is involved.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are there dangerous people?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure, but I mean, they could speak to different people that
[SPEAKER_00]: Then do the physical harm, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I mean, it seems now that they're focused on Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or in any case, that's what we have.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I don't really see any... We haven't had any encounters where
[SPEAKER_03]: you're the person who is being targeted or you're the one who showed your face or anything except for well except for in the beginning but then again nothing has happened to you during then so i i think also the what you said is also a possibility just be careful but you could check at night to see if you
[SPEAKER_03]: if there's any possibility of maybe sneaking into Professor Berkman's office.
[SPEAKER_02]: About you guys being known or whatever, remember that this is not the modern age.
[SPEAKER_02]: Knowing someone's face is pretty much impossible to track them down, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have to know someone who knows their face well enough that when you describe it to them, they go, oh, that's colder.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So just seeing someone's face is really not, you know, they don't have a photo photographic, you know, there is magic that exists.
[SPEAKER_02]: So someone can make an illusion of your face.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you maybe met a powerful magic user, they could maybe spread it that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's much harder just on face alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's more likely people are going to go to places that they can link to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, oh, we saw this guy at the Plum and Bob.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's go to the Plum and Bob again.
[SPEAKER_02]: and maybe he'll turn up again right so in terms of just having your face out there that's not so problematic it's more about the places where where you were when things happened and obviously your name because the name is more important they can track employee records or your housing or whatever right but face alone pretty hard to track anyone down yeah okay fair enough so
[SPEAKER_00]: So in the end, it could be that me and Lark get some more information.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then we meet tomorrow, we share all this information.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then once Billy is okay from the hangover, we would knock some doors, so to say.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, let's do that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess we have a plan.
[SPEAKER_07]: Where do we meet tomorrow and when?
[SPEAKER_02]: So Felix has to work again in the morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to meet again at midday after Felix's shift, if all of you want to be together, then you could meet.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can always find me now.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you say that, as you say that Felix and Asuka pulls out the watch maybe to kind of make a joke about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: The needle is now just spinning gently on its axis no longer pointing at you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have we done any?
[SPEAKER_00]: Six.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but that will come tomorrow as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys split up with your various plans, then Felix takes Billy home, Calder is going back to the dorm, Aska and Lark go to a tavern whilst and then Lark goes to visit Mira and then comes back to the tavern on the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Although we will do Lark and Calder's scene next time, I will do one small scene here as Billy, in his drunken state, gets back to his bed and falls asleep.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the nighttime, Billy
[SPEAKER_02]: You have a fitful rest, properly sleeping for the first time since your incident.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you wake up a couple of times in the night with a cold sweat.
[SPEAKER_02]: All you can remember, it was only 53 damage, all that you can remember is as you wake up that there's a,
[SPEAKER_02]: You wake up with an intense feeling of loss and sort of like heartbreak and sort of that kind of pain.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you see far off in the distance in a black void, almost nothing at all, but you see very far off in the distance a figure of a female.
[SPEAKER_02]: Every time you try and look towards her, you kind of wake up with a horrible sense of heartbreak, loss, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then you fall back to sleep in your sort of drunken state.
[SPEAKER_02]: And after a while, you're in this black void again and see just far out on the distance, this figure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's where we'll end the session.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to do the identify first or do you want to keep that for next session?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I can do the identify for you as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, yeah, because you're not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'll do the identify for you guys as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yes, this is a particular device that has clearly been made for the purposes of this
[SPEAKER_02]: variant of the locate object spell which is called locate magic and is essentially used to locate a specific spell cast
[SPEAKER_02]: The reason you believe that it's obviously no longer pointing to Felix is because it lasts only an hour.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so after the hour ran out, it was no longer pointing at Felix anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you recognize that it was not necessarily tracking Felix specifically, it was tracking a spell casting of some kind.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's presumably why I was looking at him in the first place.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, it can be used by you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's quite specific though.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if there's ever a reason in which that comes in handy, it can be used by you for the same reason.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you also learn too that the spellcaster can pass the watch over.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you kind of set it up to track and you can give it to someone else.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you get, you know, you guess that this delivery guy was just a grunt who was given the watch and is not the guy that cast the spell originally, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, but this seems very useful though in the future.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, the main problem you can see with it obviously is that it needs to be a very specific spell because in a city full of thousands of people casting magic, if you use it to find someone doing Mage Hand, you're going to be just like all over the place, whoever happens to be the nearest guy doing Mage Hand at the time, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: But if there are very specific spells that are limited to
[SPEAKER_02]: being cast, then it works for them.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess, I guess I'm gonna ask guys definitely gonna wonder like, okay, so which spell this Felix cast that made him be tracked?
[SPEAKER_03]: And yeah, that's actually still that's actually pretty big.
[SPEAKER_03]: Because then yeah, there's not that much.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, something to think about when you meet up again the following day.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then, yeah, we will also do the other bits before you guys have a long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: So don't do your long rests yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Billy, you will also level up when you do your long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can do that now if you want, because I think it's going to change for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you can do your level up as well between now and next session as well if you want to do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then that is the end of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was fun.
[SPEAKER_07]: Holy shit, what an episode.
[SPEAKER_03]: Somebody actually died in one of our sessions.
[SPEAKER_03]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, dying up minute one was not on my bingo note.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, much like how you guys get rewarded for crits.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, the guy rolled a crit on his initiative, which meant he was definitely going to go first and then crit on Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like there is just nothing
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think you guys can do about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: That just happens.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, Billy and then miss everything.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, then you got this advantage on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Billy had have gone first, for example, or just even just before the creature, then Billy probably would have gone away.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just it was just unlucky that this creature was acting first and then critical.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think I think I quit it on the most important road.
[SPEAKER_07]: Next week I can only play from Monday to Wednesday because I will be in an event from Thursday to Sunday.
[SPEAKER_07]: Is it possible any of those days?
[SPEAKER_07]: Monday, Tuesday or Wednesday?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wednesday is fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, Monday I think I have the other group anyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Tuesdays are not normally good, so it would have to be the Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll have to check for Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the 7th, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I could do Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_07]: Is it okay for me?
[SPEAKER_07]: No, to me, sorry.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is it okay for you, Crimson?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's quite quick.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, it's fine.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not that, it's Friday now.
[SPEAKER_07]: He has a whole fucking week.
[SPEAKER_02]: A week?
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not a week?
[SPEAKER_02]: Four days, are you talking about?
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, well, if you can do it Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, it'll be fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, we just do... Do you think he prepares for a new session?
[SPEAKER_03]: Come on.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I have a drop?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have a drop if you subscribe to...
[SPEAKER_02]: If you subscribe to Aeska, you get a Dungeons and Dragons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Purchase one sub or gift sub and get a D&D ampersand badge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, if you guys want a drop.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, chat.
[SPEAKER_03]: Obviously.
[SPEAKER_07]: I need my D&D badge.
[SPEAKER_07]: Batch the chat thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, the charge pattern.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get the thing that goes between the D and the D and D. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait, what time are we doing on Wednesday?
[SPEAKER_03]: Just the regular time?
[SPEAKER_04]: Same time again.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, 6?
[SPEAKER_03]: OK. Hey, Crimson's so, oh my god.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_03]: I wonder why.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thanks, Crimson.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's kind of a cool patch, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's cool that you can get that just by something.
[SPEAKER_03]: And truly so.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_03]: Almost hungry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any primes in the chat?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you show the badge?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know how you turn them on, honestly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I found it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, I should have waited before.
[SPEAKER_03]: Too late, you're stuck now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hey, there's the badge.
[SPEAKER_02]: You click on the, where it says chat identity next to send a message and then you pick global badge.
[SPEAKER_07]: Where is chat identity?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, it's like where it says send a message in the, in the chat box on the left, it has your sub badge, but you can click that and change whether you showed the sub badge and whatever you showed, whatever.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's, that's actually a pretty cool badge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, fun.
[SPEAKER_02]: But now it says like Aeska and Grimsenaire cause it's like a,
[SPEAKER_02]: and symbol between your sub-gen, I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, that's pretty cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: I assure you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sick.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, cool, Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, cool, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, yeah, OK, so we get to, we get to, OK, so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Man, they have a, I'm not doing this yet, but they have a gift sub to everyone who's currently watching.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I know, I know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Since when?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's crazy.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, they also introduced a 1000 sub drop, so you could literally give 1000 subs.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I save 1.5k by gifting a thousand euros.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can you imagine that shit?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like, hey, why don't you give out three and a half thousand euros just so that you could save one and a half thousand euros?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh my god, crazy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Stupid thing from Twitch.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, good game, guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: GG, everyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: GG's.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was a good session, except that Kimmy died.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it started off fun.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody actually died.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will say I was lenient because you had a solution but I'm not gonna, if somebody else dies and you're in the middle of nowhere and there is no solution to that, you're not saving everyone's life by
[SPEAKER_03]: chance oh yeah in this in this scenario there was they did happen to be the kind of perfect yeah scenario so yeah yeah because we also know enough about these constructs now to know that like it's it's a sort of like a beating heart for the construct you know so then it's like oh shit we need to do something quickly let's just
[SPEAKER_00]: And it was so cool, like instantly when Billy went down, I'm like, oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then Lark also started to DM me, like, what the fuck?
[SPEAKER_00]: But I don't know, it was also super cool then to like, wait, but I wonder if this actually works, if it works on Felix, maybe we can make a zombie Billy as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I guess it kind of makes sense.
[SPEAKER_03]: And also with the severity of the situation at the moment, you know, it's like, oh shit, we just killed something, but Billy's dead, we need to do something.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then it's like, and then Asker is like, oh shit, shit, chorus and stuff, let's just fucking shove stuff in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hey, it worked, you know?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that's a bit of a wake-up call that some enemies are going to be dangerous.
[SPEAKER_07]: What do you mean wake-up call?
[SPEAKER_07]: We had no chance of helping.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean, it's a wake-up call that you got to be careful.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can just get one shot.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was like knock knock and Billy's like, who's there?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: no it was more like knock knock who's there the guy whiffed his cudgel you killed two people and in response got killed so it's not like you're completely innocent in this situation the guy tried to hit you with a club and you responded by basically shooting them both in the face and then you're like oh then a guy killed me you know well yeah
[SPEAKER_02]: In this scenario, you were the NPC to the other guy, to the beast.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guy was like, this guy's in my way, just get rid of him.
[SPEAKER_02]: One more time, how do I do the badge thingy?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where it says send a message in the chat at the bottom, where it says send a message, you type that.
[SPEAKER_02]: On the left side of that, there's a chat sub badge.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you click that, you can change to other stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can also see all the badges that you have.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have CSGO week Brazil 2022.
[SPEAKER_03]: The only one I can flex with is my 2017 TwitchCon Los Angeles badge.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the only one.
[SPEAKER_03]: The rest is like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have TwitchCon 2020 in Amsterdam.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's kind of cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: TwitchCon 2019 in Berlin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I have that too.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I remember we drove there together.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, there's Pokemon.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got this one that says I went outside.
[SPEAKER_04]: IRL, let's go.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've never been outside before.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: Also, Maken, if you have time to go through the stories or link them to me.
[SPEAKER_07]: This one's going to be so...
[SPEAKER_00]: Cinematic.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I am really looking forward to the pictures that they are generating.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I really am.
[SPEAKER_03]: Honestly, it's going to be so much fun.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: I can see one where you see Eska just wiping his brow with Felix and Colin next to him, and then Billy is just like,
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it might be difficult to do some of the surgery scenes with yeah, potentially the aftermaths of those things.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, yeah, very good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right, guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Catch you guys later.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bye bye.